I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Today we are talking about the Valentine's Day episode. I am so excited for this one. Me too. I liked this one so much I watched it an extra time in my prep. I did too. Just for pleasure. I did too. My husband, Josh, was like, babe, how many times are you gonna watch that episode? I was like, I am really enjoying it. I think this one sneaked up on
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。今天我们来聊聊情人节那一集。我对这一集超级期待。我也是。我太喜欢这一集了，在做准备时我还多看了一遍。我也是。纯粹为了享受。我也是。我丈夫乔什就问我，宝贝，那一集你要看多少遍？我说，我是真的很喜欢。我觉得这一集悄悄地
me because there are certain episodes that I remember as being favorites. Yeah. And this one was not on my radar. And then I watched it and so many memories came back to you. So many. Okay. This is a goodie. This is season two, episode 16, written by Mike Schurr and directed by Greg Daniels. I mean, honestly, that's all you need to know. Right there. That's like the super team. Yeah. Of course, this is a great one. All right. I'll give a summary. It's Valentine's Day at Dunder, Mifflin. Michael has to go to the corporate offices in New York. He has to meet and do a presentation for the new CFO, Chief Financial Officer. It's a big deal. It is. And he's gonna be there with Jan on Valentine's Day.
吸引了我，因为有些集数我一直记忆犹新，觉得它们是我的最爱。是的。而这一集并不在我的雷达范围内。然后我看了它，好多回忆都涌上心头。真的好多。好吧。这一集很棒。这是第二季第16集，由迈克·舒尔编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。说实话，你只需要知道这些。就在这儿。这就像是梦幻团队。是的。当然，这一集棒极了。好吧。我来总结一下。今天是邓德米夫林的情人节。迈克尔得去纽约的公司总部。他必须去见新任首席财务官（CFO）并向其做简报。这是一件大事。确实是。而且他要在情人节那天和简一起呆在那里。
Oh, no. Back at the office, Phyllis is overwhelmed by gifts from her boyfriend, Bob Vance, Advanced Refrigeration. They just come all day, these gifts. All day. Pam patiently waits for a gift from Roy that never comes. No, no. And she really dolled herself up. Oh, yes. That's my fast fact number one, Angela. Do it. Do it. Fan question from Baltimore Ashley. What was the thought process behind Pam's hair for this episode? Was there another special meeting? I bet there was. Oh, my gosh, you guys. I also got similar questions from Casey McMillan and many other people asking if there was a special meeting for Pam's hair. There was more than a meeting. It was like the Joint Chiefs of Staff. It was. Came together for
噢，不。回到办公室里，菲利斯被她的男友——高级制冷公司的鲍勃·凡斯送来的礼物淹没了。这些礼物一整天都在送来。一整天。潘耐心地等待着罗伊的礼物，但礼物始终没来。没有，真的没有。而且她把自己打扮得漂漂亮亮。哦，是的。那是我的第一号冷知识，安吉拉。说吧。说吧。巴尔的摩的阿什莉发来的粉丝提问。潘在这一集里的发型背后有什么构思吗？是不是还有另一个特别会议？我敢说肯定有。天哪，各位。我还收到了来自凯西·麦克米兰以及许多其他人的类似问题，他们都在问是不是为潘的发型开过一个特别会议。那可不止是一个会议。那简直就像参谋长联席会议。确实是。为了
your hair. So the thought process here was that Pam and Jim in this episode, they're going to be a bit estranged. So wouldn't it be an extra nail in the coffin for Jim if Pam just looked super duper cute? Right. So we thought, can we please do something different with her hair? I had a MySpace blog at the time and I wrote about my hair. And I said that Kim Ferry and I worked for weeks on different versions of this look. Well, now in Kim Ferry, like I do, like you do, she must have been so excited because she was so good at hair, but she never got to do much with our hair. No. Okay. So here's what we tried. We tried a ponytail, a barrette and headbands. We took a picture of each choice and we presented
你的发型聚到了一起。所以这里的构思是，潘和吉姆在这集里关系会变得有些疏远。那么，如果潘看起来超级无敌可爱，对吉姆来说会不会是雪上加霜呢？对吧。所以我们想，能不能在她的发型上做点不一样的尝试？我当时有一个MySpace博客，我在上面写了我的发型。我说过，我和金·费里花了几个星期的时间研究这个造型的不同版本。现在，就像我一样，像你一样，金·费里一定超级兴奋，因为她很擅长做发型，但她从没怎么有机会在我们的头发上发挥。没有。好吧。所以我们尝试了这些：我们尝试了马尾辫、发夹和发带。我们给每种选择拍了照片，然后把它们展示
them to Greg Daniels and he went through the photos and had to pick hairstyle and he picked the headband. And there were various headbands. I was going to say, were there 12 different headbands? Yes. Yes. So it was and also ponytails. High pony, low pony, side pony. No side pony. Well, side pony shows up later at the art fair. I wore a side ponytail to my prom. My, I think it was my senior year I did a side pony. I was not cool guys. You did a side pony to prom? Yeah. I did a side. Did you get that done at a salon or did you do that at home? No, my mom did it. My mom did it. And that was the year, the year before we had all had dates and none of us had a good time. My group of like really close girlfriends.
给格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他翻看这些照片，必须挑出一个发型，然后他挑了发带。而且有很多不同的发带。我正想说，当时有12种不同的发带吗？是的。是的。所以就是这样，还有马尾辫。高马尾、低马尾、侧马尾。没有侧马尾。哦，侧马尾后来在艺术展上出现了。我参加毕业舞会时扎过侧马尾。我，我想大概是我高三那年我扎了个侧马尾。我当时可真不酷，各位。你扎着侧马尾去参加毕业舞会？对。我扎了一个。那是你在美发沙龙弄的，还是你在家里自己弄的？没有，我妈给我弄的。我妈弄的。那是那一年，前一年我们大家都有舞伴，但谁也没玩开心。我和我那一群特别要好的闺蜜。
So that was the year the guys thought they were being really cool and they're like, we're not going to take dates this year. I went to a small school. And so the girls were like, fine. And we had the best time. Was that your senior prom? Our senior prom. I danced in a circle with all my girlfriends with a side ponytail. Lady, I did an all girls prom for my senior prom too. You did. We would have been in the same dance circle. We would have. You would have loved my side pony. I have a card about that fast fact. Tell it. I mean, not only is it Pam's hair, Pam is wearing a pink sweater. Her headbands pink. She has a heart necklace on. She has pink earrings on. I mean, little pink dangle earrings. I
所以那一年，男生们觉得自己酷毙了，他们说，我们今年不带舞伴了。我读的是一所小学校。所以女生们就说，好吧。结果我们玩得最开心。那是你们的高中毕业舞会吗？我们的高中毕业舞会。我扎着侧马尾，和所有的闺蜜围成一圈跳舞。天哪，我的高中毕业舞会也是一个全女生的舞会。真的吗。那我们会在同一个跳舞的圈子里。确实会。你会喜欢我的侧马尾的。我有一张关于那个冷知识的卡片。讲讲吧。我的意思是，不仅是潘的头发，潘还穿着一件粉色毛衣。她的发带是粉色的。她戴着心形项链。她戴着粉色耳环。我是说，小巧的粉色吊坠耳环。我
know the lady came like she came to be noticed. She did. She's I think a little lip gloss. Yes. It was a whole look. I have to say, when I first saw myself on screen, I was a little bit like, oh, oh, Pam, Pam went for it. Pam showed up today. And I mean, I mean, it's going to play out later in the episode. But like, Roy, come on. This is someone who clearly wants a Valentine, no matter what she says. Okay. Sorry. Fast fact. Number two, fast fact. Number two, a portion of this episode was shot in New York City. We got a lot of questions about this. People wanted to know if we did Steve stand in front of a green screen? Did we shoot on the streets of Los Angeles? No. But there's more questions, Angela. Okay.
知道这姑娘来的时候就是为了引人注目。她确实是。我觉得她还涂了一点唇彩。对。整个造型非常完整。我必须得说，当我第一次在屏幕上看到自己时，我心里有点像，哦，哦，潘，潘太拼了。潘今天盛装出席了。而且我的意思是，我的意思是，这会在后面的剧情中展现出来。但像罗伊，拜托。这是一个无论她嘴上怎么说，心里都显然想要一个情人的人。好吧。抱歉。第二号冷知识，第二号冷知识。这一集的一部分是在纽约市拍摄的。我们收到了很多关于这个的问题。人们想知道史蒂夫是不是站在绿幕前演的？我们是在洛杉矶的街道上拍摄的吗？不是的。但还有更多问题，安吉拉。好吧。
A fan question from Cora Louise. How many crew members came to New York City? And Guava Aora asked, how long did it take to shoot this episode in New York and was the rest of the cast in California? Yes. We did not get to go. We did not. We were all pretty bummed because it sounded like so much fun. So I reached out to Randall Einhorn, our director of photography. Jenna, you know, I did this. I know. And you guys, she wouldn't tell me what he said. She's got all this good information about the New York shoot and she made me wait. Well, this is something we do. We both love to like dig up nuggets of info and then we don't tell each other because we want the surprise. I know. Well, I've been waiting
来自科拉·露易丝的粉丝提问。有多少剧组成员去了纽约市？瓜娃·奥拉问，在纽约拍摄这一集花多长时间，其他演员是不是都在加州？是的。我们没能去。我们没有。我们都挺沮丧的，听起来好像太有趣了。所以我联系了我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾恩霍恩。珍娜，你知道的，我这么做了。我知道。而且你们大家伙儿，她不肯告诉我他说的话。她掌握了所有关于纽约拍摄的精彩幕后信息，却让我干等着。好吧，这是我们常做的事。我们俩都喜欢搜集各种信息边角料，然后不告诉对方，因为我们想要保留惊喜。我懂。好吧，我为此已经等了
like five days for this. Okay. Here we go. So I reached out to Randall and he said the crew in New York was just him and Greg and Steve that would go out on the street when they would film. Yeah. And in the van, they had like, I think two crew members that were New York based like, because they had to do things by the rules, you know, and our line producer Kent Zabornak. But whenever the van doors would open, it would just be Greg, Steve and Randall. He said that this was right at the height of 40 year old Virgin. It was the biggest movie in America. He said there was a billboard in Times Square where they were filming. So he said the minute Steve would get out of the van, a crowd would form. So
大约五天了。好吧。我们开始吧。所以我联系了兰德尔，他说在纽约的剧组只有他和格雷格以及史蒂夫，他们会在拍摄时走到街上去。是的。而在面包车里，他们大概有，我想有两名纽约本地的剧组人员，因为他们必须按规矩办事，你知道的，还有我们的制片主任肯特·扎博纳克。但每当面包车门打开时，就只有格雷格、史蒂夫和兰德尔。他说这正值《四十岁的老处男》大火的时候。那是全美最卖座的电影。他说他们拍摄的时候，时代广场上就有一块巨幅广告牌。所以他说史蒂夫一从面包车里出来，人群就会聚拢过来。所以
he said they had to move really fast and quickly. And he said he used a handy cam camera, like a basic handy cam camera that you could buy at Costco. Whoa. It's a really small camera. So not to draw a lot of attention to them. Yeah. Because the minute people saw Steve, literally he said a crowd would form. Well, wasn't this also right after his Golden Globe win? Oh, yes. Yes. It was all of that. He just won the Golden Globe. There was a billboard of him in Times Square, and they're going to film on the streets of New York. Bonkers. Now, this was scripted, though. They had certain scripted spots, but I know that Steve was also improvising and riffing at the same time. It was very loosey-goosey. That's true. That's
他说他们必须动作非常快、非常迅速。并且他说他用了一台手持摄像机，就像那种你在好市门（Costco）就能买到的基础款手持摄像机。哇。那是一台很小的摄像机。为了不引起太多注意。对。因为人们一看到史蒂夫，字面意义上，他说人群就会聚集起来。等等，这不也正好是在他赢得金球奖之后吗？哦，是的。是的。就是所有这些事情。他刚赢得金球奖。时代广场上有他的巨幅广告牌，而他们要在纽约街头拍摄。太疯狂了。现在，不过这其实是有剧本的。他们有一些既定的剧本情节，但我知道史蒂夫同时也一直在即兴发挥和自由发挥。现场非常自由散漫。确实是。确实是。
true. So I asked Randall, okay, what were some of the things that you know were scripted? He said the Rockefeller Center portion was scripted. He said that Sabaro was scripted. But he said that he's pretty sure when Steve goes into the subway and sees a man pooping in the box, that that was improv. That was Steve just goofing around. But Steve did a lot of improv. Like, whenever they saw something or they had a moment, he would hop out. You know, there's a tag at the end of like the Fiddler on the roof, like him goofing around. That's improv. There's a bunch of deleted scenes of him on the streets of New York that I think are a lot of improvisations. They're fantastic. The deleted scenes for this are great, and
所以我问兰德尔，好吧，你知道哪些部分是有剧本的？他说洛克菲勒中心的部分是有剧本的。他说赛百味（Subaro）的部分是有剧本的。但他说他很确信，当史蒂夫走进地铁，看到一个男的在一个箱子里大便时，那是即兴发挥。那是史蒂夫在胡闹。但史蒂夫做了很多即兴发挥。比如，每当他们看到什么或者有一个情绪点时，他就会跳出来。你知道的，就像《屋顶上的提琴手》结尾有一个彩蛋，他在里面胡闹。那是即兴发挥。还有一堆他在纽约街头的被删减片段，我觉得里面有很多即兴发挥。它们太棒了。这一集的被删减片段非常棒，
I'll bring up some more of them later. And then I said, Randall, is there like a fun story or a memory you have from filming in New York that maybe doesn't even have anything to do with the episode? And he said, yes. This is what he said. He said the night they got into New York, just him and Steve went to this place called Johnny's and they got beer and pizza. He said he thought the pizza was pepperoni. But he just said it was really special and they were walking back to their hotel, walking through Times Square. And he said there were billboards everywhere. A 40 year old virgin with Steve's face, like all over the place. And the show is getting popular. Steve had just won a Golden Globe. So it was
我待会儿会多聊几个。然后我问，兰德尔，你在纽约拍摄时有没有什么有趣的故事或记忆，也许甚至和这一集一点关系都没有？他说，有。他是这么说的。他说他们到达纽约的那天晚上，只有他和史蒂夫，他们去了个叫强尼（Johnny）的地方喝了啤酒，吃了披萨。他说他以为披萨是意大利辣香肠味的。但他只是说这真的很特别，他们走回酒店，穿过时代广场。他说到处都是广告牌。到处都是《四十岁的老处男》上面史蒂夫的脸。而且这部剧越来越受欢迎。史蒂夫刚刚赢得金球奖。所以
kind of surreal to walk through all of those billboards of Steve. And people started coming up to Steve. And Randall said that Steve was as gracious and kind to the first person who stopped him as he was to the 100th. He just was so kind and in the moment. But that is Steve. He is so kind and gracious. And Randall just said it was really special. I think for him and Steve to just have that night together like that, just grabbing a slice and a beer and being in New York, I'm sure it felt really cool. Aww. I love that. I know, me too. That's one of the cool things about the show where there's some circumstance that brings you to an experience you would not have normally
走在所有那些史蒂夫的广告牌中间，感觉有点超现实。人们开始向史蒂夫走来。兰德尔说，史蒂夫对第一个拦住他的人和对第一百个人一样亲切友好。他就是那么友善，完全投入在当下。但这就是史蒂夫。他是如此友善和亲切。兰德尔只是说这真的很特别。我想对他和史蒂夫来说，能一起度过那样一个夜晚，去买块披萨和一杯啤酒，身处纽约，那种感觉肯定酷极了。啊。我太喜欢这个了。我知道，我也是。这是这部剧很酷的特色之一，某些机缘巧合会带你体验到你平时根本不可能获得的经历。
had. Yeah. Yeah. So cool. So cool. And Greg and Kintz Bornack talk a little bit more about New York and the DVD commentary. So if you want to give that a listen. All right, Jenna, that's my New York City nuggets. They were great and they were worth waiting for.
对啊。对啊。太酷了。太酷了。而且格雷格和肯特·扎博纳克在DVD评论音轨里还多聊了聊纽约的事情。所以如果你想听的话可以去听听看。好了，珍娜，这就是我的纽约市幕后爆料。它们很棒，而且绝对值得等待。
Thank you. I loved them. Thank you. Fast fact number three. In this episode, we meet the new CFO of Dunder Mifflin, David Wallace. Hey now. Hey. Hey, hey.
谢谢你。我很喜欢。谢谢你。第三号冷知识。在这一集里，我们见到了邓德米夫林的新任首席财务官大卫·华莱士。嘿，大家好。嘿。嘿，嘿。
Who's here? Hey now. Hi, Andy Buckley. There we go. Who is in studio with us now. I'm going to put on the Wallace glasses. Put on the Wallace glasses. Bam.
谁来啦？嘿，大家好。嗨，安迪·巴克利。我们到了。现在和我们一起在录音室里的是谁。我要戴上华莱士眼镜了。戴上华莱士眼镜。嘭。
Andy, you appeared in 37 episodes of the show. Yeah. 37. That's crazy. Yeah. Here's some stuff I learned about you by looking you up on the internet. Well, get ready. We should say the three of us are friends in real life.
安迪，你一共出演了37集剧集。对。37集。太疯狂了。对。这是我在网上搜索你时了解到的关于你的一些事情。好吧，做好准备。我们得先说，我们三个在现实生活中是好朋友。
Yeah. So it was a little bit interesting to Google a friend. Yeah. But here's some things I learned about you. None of it is true. Oh boy. But it's probably all true. That's good to know.
对。所以去谷歌搜索一个朋友感觉有点意思。对。但这是我了解到的关于你的一些事情。没有一条是真的。哦天哪。但可能全都是真的。那就好知道了。
It's probably all true. You were born in Boston. Yep. Salem, Massachusetts, grew up in Marblehead, Swampskate, Peabody, mostly Marblehead. And I have the SmartPak. You do? You do? John Krasinski, SmartPak.
可能全都是真的。你出生在波士顿。没错。马萨诸塞州塞勒姆，在马布尔黑德、斯万斯科特、皮布蒂长大，主要是马布尔黑德。我有SmartPak。你真的有？你有？约翰·卡拉辛斯基，SmartPak。
You graduated from Stanford University. Yeah. But you got a degree in political science. Yes. That was... Not theater, not acting. No. So I did, I was a golfer in high school and I went there to play golf.
你毕业于斯坦福大学。对。但你拿的是政治学学位。是的。那是……不是戏剧，不是表演。没。所以，我是高中的高尔夫球手，我去那里是为了打高尔夫。
Like I was on the golf team. Like on a golf scholarship? Yeah. They didn't have a ton of money, but I was, I got in through the golf program and they gave you a thousand bucks. You're a good golfer. And I used to be. I'm still good, but I used to be.
就像我是高尔夫校队的一员。是通过高尔夫特长生进去的吗？对。他们没有一大笔钱，但我通过高尔夫项目被录取了，他们给了你一千块钱。你是个优秀的高尔夫球手。我以前是。我现在打得也还行，但我以前很厉害。
But yes. So and I was a polycymer. I did, I did plays there and I had done plays in high school also and loved acting and saw a James Dean movie when I was in high school and thought I was going to be like a brooding young... Brooding golf playing. Yes. James Dean.
但是，是的。所以我主修政治学。我在那里演过话剧，我在高中时也演过话剧，非常热爱表演，我上高中时看过一部詹姆斯·迪恩的电影，以为自己会成为一个像那样郁郁寡欢的年轻……郁郁寡欢的打高尔夫的……是的。詹姆斯·迪恩。
All of the above. Political science. And none of it... James Dean. But when you were cast on the show, you were working as a wealth management advisor, which I believe is a fancy word for stockbroker. That's exactly it. Yeah.
以上皆是。政治学。然而并没有……詹姆斯·迪恩。但当你被剧组选中时，你正在从事财富管理顾问的工作，我相信这是股票经纪人的高大上说法。完全正确。是的。
At Merrill Lynch. Yes. I study acting. I moved to Los Angeles. It does not go well for the first like seven or eight or nine years. I get little bits and pieces here, Allison Jones being possibly my only fan, luckily. And my wife, who was then my girlfriend, said, you got to, you got to change it up. This is crazy.
在美林证券（Merrill Lynch）。对。我学习表演。我搬到了洛杉矶。前七、八、九年情况很不妙。我得到一些零星的小角色，艾莉森·琼斯可能是我唯一的粉丝，幸好有她。我的妻子，当时还是我的女朋友，她说，你得，你得改变一下了。这太疯狂了。
Like, you can't just keep doing these odd jobs and then think you're going to get hired. She was like, get a job. Get a job. Literally, basically get a job. And there was an old acting buddy of mine who was working there and he would still audition. He said, oh, come interview me. You might be great for it. And they hire me.
就像，你不能一直做这些零工，然后还指望有人雇佣你。她就说，去找个工作。去找个工作。字面意思，基本上就是去找个工作。我有一个以前的表演老搭档也在那里工作，他平时还会去试镜。他说，哦，来面试我吧。你可能很适合这份工作。然后他们就雇佣了我。
And I, you know, I loved it. It was crazy. I loved it. So I started there in 2001 and was there and that's all I was doing. And then we got married and we had our first son. I bumped into Allison Jones or like the local farmer's market on large month. And you're, you're, and I'm just a guy getting up and being in the office at six and talking to clients or, you know, potential clients or, and, and I see her and what are you doing
而且，你知道，我很喜欢。这太疯狂了。我很喜欢。所以我2001年开始在那里上班，一直呆在那儿，那是我唯一的全职工作。然后我们结婚了，有了我们的第一个儿子。我在大月份的当地农夫市场上偶遇了艾莉森·琼斯。而你，而你，我只是一个早上六点起床去办公室、和客户或者潜在客户交谈的普通人，然后我看到了她，你最近在忙什么呢，
Buckley? I haven't seen you in a while. Stockbroker. I'm married. I got a kid. I got like Mr. Grownup and she says, well, give me your card just in case something comes up. You never know.
巴克利？我好一阵子没见你了。股票经纪人。我结婚了。我有个孩子。我搞得就像个成年人先生，然后她说，把你的名片给我一张，以防万一有什么角色合适。你永远不知道嘛。
I mean, would you want to do it? I can't. Sure. I guess if it's in town and without her mentioning anything or thinking, you know, four months almost later, she calls me, it's like Buckley, I can't believe I found this card, but I'm glad I did. I think you might be the right guy. You should come audition for this, you know, the boss on the office, you know, the show
我是说，你想演吗？我不知道。当然。我想如果是本地拍摄的话。她甚至都没提别的或者想太多，（过）了差不多四个月后，她打电话给我，说巴克利，真不敢相信我找到这张名片了，但我很高兴我找到了。我觉得你可能是合适的人选。你应该来为这个角色试镜，你知道的，就是《办公室》里的老板，你知道这部剧
and it's like, yeah, of course I know the show like, yeah, he's the financial guy and you're a financial guy. They might like that. You should audition. And it was great. So I go in and say, hi, do the first scene. But I read with Allison, it was Mike, sure, in the room and it was just the two of them. So I read with Allison, I do the first scene and then the second scene and then Michael
然后我就说，对，我当然知道这部剧，然后就，对，他是财务主管，而你是个财务人员。他们可能会喜欢这个。你应该去试镜。这太棒了。所以我去了，打招呼，演了第一场戏。我和艾莉森搭戏，迈克·舒尔也在房间里，当时就他们俩。所以我跟艾莉森搭戏，演了第一场戏，然后是第二场戏，接着迈克
says, now you're, you're like, you're, you're a financial, what do you, you're like some kind of financial guy. Right. Now, knowing Mike the way we know Mike, he loved that. I know that he loved that, that you were actually working at Merrill Lynch was probably one of the coolest things to him. I figure that's why I got hired. And then I go back to my office and I'm like, all right.
说，现在你，你就像，你是一个财务，你算什么，你就像某种财务人员吧。对。现在，用我们对迈克的了解来看，他太喜欢这个了。我知道他非常喜欢这一点，你实际上在美林证券工作，对她来说可能是最酷的事情之一。我想这就是我被录用的原因。然后我回到办公室，心想，好吧。
And you just go about your day and then the next morning, Allison calls and says, hey, they're going to hire you. And it was so excited. I was so excited. It was like, oh man, this will be awesome. And at the time I thought, well, maybe like, I guess it'll be cool. I'll get to be on the show like once a year or something like that or twice. I mean, that'll be fun.
然后你照常过你的一天，第二天早上，艾莉森打电话来说，嘿，他们要雇佣你了。当时太激动了。我超级兴奋。心想，哦天哪，这太棒了。当时我想，好吧，也许吧，我想这会挺酷的。我可以一年上一次这部剧或者类似这样的节目，或者两次。我的意思是，那会很有趣。
And yeah, I was going to ask you, when you auditioned, did they say this was one episode with the possibility of more? Or did they give you any indication that this might lead to 37 episodes? No, they didn't say anything. And I mean, that was it. It was so whatever day the audition was and then the next week, I guess I did it. Now where did you film the boardroom scenes? My memory is that it was right next to our Dunder Mifflin set that you could walk from
对啊，我正想问你，当你去试镜时，他们有没有说过这是一集戏，但未来有继续出演的可能？或者他们有没有给你任何暗示，这可能会发展成37集？不，他们什么都没说。我的意思是，就是这样。无论是哪天试镜，然后第二周，我想我就去拍了。现在，你们的董事会场景是在哪儿拍的？我的记忆是它就在我们邓德米夫林的布景旁边，你可以直接从我们的布景走到你们的布景。
our set to your set. Right. That's what it was. You were just right there. I was right there and I show up and Steve couldn't have been nicer. You know, everybody couldn't have been nicer. And it was just, it was fun because Greg would come up and he would say, great, that was good.
没错。就是那样的。你们就在旁边。我就在旁边，我去了，史蒂夫态度好得不能再好了。你知道的，每个人态度都好得不得了。这很有趣，因为格雷格会走过来对我说，太棒了，演得真好。
Okay. And they said, let's try it this way. And he would have an idea, which I can't, I was trying to think like, what were his specific ideas? And it was along the lines of like, do this one as if you just want to keep things calm. Do this one as if you're a little irritated and he just sort of subtle, subtle changes. This is in the great Scott, you know, when he shows the video. Oh my goodness.
好吧。然后他们说，我们换个方式试一次。他会有一个想法，我当时想绞尽脑汁去想，他的具体想法是什么？大致的方向就像是，把这段演得好像你只想保持冷静。把这段演得好像你有点被激怒了，就是诸如此类微妙的变化。这就是那个“太棒了，斯科特”的环节，你知道的，就是他播放视频的时候。哦，天哪。
You guys, your facial reactions to the video that Michael makes is so amazing. It was so wonderful. So when do you get the call that they want you back for another episode? A year later. A year later. A year later. Oh my gosh, Andy. The most great Allison calls and says, Buckley, you're in an episode in a couple of weeks
伙计们，你们对迈克尔制作的那个视频的面部反应太精彩了。太绝了。所以你是什么时候接到电话，说他们想让你回归拍另一集的？一年后。一年后。一年后。哦，天哪，安迪。最棒的是艾莉森打电话来说，巴克利，你过几个星期要拍一集，
and you're all over it. Like you're having a party at your house. Everybody's there. It's crazy. And, and she's like, and JJ Abrams is directing. Like it's, it's crazy. You're like, wait, I have some meetings I have to re-erase. Exactly.
而且戏份很多。就像你在自己家里办派对一样。所有人都去了。这太疯狂了。而且，她说JJ·艾布拉姆斯要来当导演。这太疯狂了。你就想，等等，我得重新安排一些会议。没错。
I'm going to change around. But it was after we hired Ryan at the very end of season three that I kind of thought, oh, maybe I'll get to be on this like two or three times. He's like, we're coming to corporate. He's coming to corporate. Maybe I'll get to be on it. You could see a possible story in life. I thought, yeah.
我要调整一下日程。但直到第三季末我们雇用了瑞恩之后，我才心想，哦，也许我能在这个节目里露脸两三次。他就说，我们要去总公司了。他要去总公司了。也许我能参演。你能看出生活中潜在的故事线。我想，嗯。
Like, oh, wow. Do you get recognized a lot? Do people scream, suck it at you? Yes. And then do other people wonder why people are screaming, suck it at you? It's funny. And I definitely haven't sometimes. And it's, and all of this has started to happen so much more in the last three or four years
就像，哦，哇。你经常被认出来吗？人们会冲你大喊“吸干它”（Suck It）吗？是的。然后其他人会纳闷为什么有人冲你喊“吸干它”吗？这挺逗的。而且我有几次确实没搞懂。并且，这一切在过去的三四年里发生得越来越频繁了，
because of Netflix and the show was so much bigger and everything. Yeah. Andy, do you still work at Merrill Lynch? No. So I left the last season of the show was when I finally left. So you've gone on to do a bunch of stuff now. You're now a full-time actor. What are you working on right now?
因为有了Netflix，这部剧变得更火了，诸如此类的。是的。安迪，你现在还在美林证券工作吗？不在了。所以直到这部剧的最后一季，我才终于离开了。所以你现在转型做了很多其他的事。你现在是一名全职演员了。你现在在忙些什么？
What can we tell people where to find you now? Super, super lucky. So let's see. So that I'm get to be on a cast once again by Allison Jones, this HBO show called Avenue Five, which is super funny. And it's the fellow that wrote created Veep. It's his new show. We're on this crazy, you know, we're on a cruise ship, luxury cruise ship in outer space.
我们能告诉大家去哪里找到你吗？超级、超级幸运。让我想想。所以，我再次被艾莉森·库司选中了演员阵容，出演了一部HBO的剧集叫《第五大道》（Avenue Five），超级搞笑。而且它的创剧人就是写《副总统》的那个人。这是他的新剧。我们在一个疯狂的，你知道的，我们在太空中坐一艘豪华游轮。
Like, it's, it's just a cruise ship, but it's 30 years from now. So we're in space, as if Elon Musk or Richard Berger, right? Right. I had finally figured it out. And Hugh Laurie is the captain of the ship and Josh and Zach Woods is on it. It's great. Because, uh, oh my goodness, is he so funny because I never acted with him like basically he came in as I was.
就像，这只是一艘游轮，但背景是30年后的未来。所以我们在太空中，就像埃隆·马斯克或者理查德·布兰森一样？没错。我终于搞明白了。休·劳瑞是飞船的船长，乔什和扎克·伍兹也在里面。太棒了，因为，哦天哪，他是那么搞笑，因为我以前从没和他演过戏，基本上他进来的时候我就在。
He is so funny and he's so smart. He's so smart. He's so smart. Thank you so, so much. Thank you for coming. You guys can find Andy on Instagram as well. On Twitter. You've got quite a nice Twitter.
他是那么搞笑，而且他太聪明了。他太聪明了。他太聪明了。非常非常感谢你。谢谢你来到这里。大家也可以在Instagram上找到安迪。还有Twitter。你的Twitter经营得相当不错。
We'll tell us your handle. I'm at just Andy Buckley. And then on Instagram, I am Andy Buckley 2020 in case I decide to run for an office. Great. But just for this year. Just for this year. Well, I am following you, Andy Buckley 2020 on the Insta. I appreciate it.
告诉我们你的账号吧。我是@just_andy_buckley。然后在Instagram上，我是Andy Buckley 2020，以防我决定竞选某个公职。太棒了。但只限今年。只限今年。好吧，我在Insta上关注了你，Andy Buckley 2020。我很感激。
We're Instapel. I appreciate it. I know. And you'll have to come back. You'll have to come back. Yeah, you are. I would love to come back. Do you have 36 more episodes?
我们是Insta好基友。我很感激。我知道。你以后还得再来。你必须得回来。对，你是。我很乐意再来。你们还有36集没聊完呢？
Yeah. That's, I, I. And we've only really covered your origin story. Yeah. So there's more to, there's more to talk about. All right, Andy. Thank you. Thank you very much.
对。我，我。而且我们其实只聊了你的起源故事。是的。所以还有更多内容，还有更多可以聊的。好吧，安迪。谢谢你。非常感谢。
Thank you for having me, ladies. And we're back. Hello. Let's start breaking down the Valentine's Day episode. Let's get into it, lady. All right. So we start with a Pam talking head. She explains it's a Valentine's Day.
谢谢你们邀请我，女士们。我们回来了。哈喽。让我们开始剖析情人节这一集吧。我们切入正题吧，女士。好吧。所以我们从潘的单人访谈开始。她解释今天是情人节。
This is not your typical cold open where it's a standalone kind of prank or joke. This applies to the story of the episode. We noted earlier her hair is down. She's got her sparkly headband on. She actually says, I like Valentine's Day in this office. Yeah. Cause we all hand things out to each other. She talks about how last year Jim gave her a card, a hilarious card with Dwight's face
这可不是那种独立的小恶作剧或笑话的典型冷场开场白。这与这一集的剧情息息相关。我们前面注意到她披散着头发。她戴着闪亮的发带。她甚至说，我喜欢办公室里的情人节。是的。因为我们都会互相分发小东西。她谈到去年吉姆送了她一张卡片，一张印有德怀特脸的搞笑卡片。
on it. It was so funny. But then she says that her and Roy are saving money this year for the wedding. So she told him not to get anything too big. But she's still clearly expecting something. She still wants something. Well I have a few little background things for this talking head. Okay.
太搞笑了。但接着她说她和罗伊今年为了婚礼正在攒钱。所以她告诉罗伊不要买太贵重的东西。但她显然还是很期待收到什么。她还是想要点东西。好吧，我为这个单人访谈准备了一些背景小料。好的。
That I found very interesting. Yes. So behind our talking heads was normally you could see Leslie David Baker, who plays Stanley, our Phyllis. Yeah. At their desks. You would never see Jim behind you during a talking head because his desk is over closer to Pam's at reception.
我觉得非常有趣。是的。所以我们的单人访谈背景里，通常你能看到饰演斯坦利、我们的菲利斯的莱斯利·大卫·贝克。还有我们的菲利斯。是的。在他们的办公桌旁。在单人访谈时，你绝对不会在身后看到吉姆，因为他的办公桌靠近前台潘的座位。
Is Jim in the background of this? Jim is in the background of your talking head. He's like sitting over there talking to Creed. You can see him in the, in the distance. And you know, I was listening to the DVD commentary and one of the things that Greg and Mike talked about was in this episode, Jim and Pam barely speak. Yeah. But they're always in the foreground or background of each other shots.
吉姆在这个背景里吗？吉姆在你的单人访谈背景里。他就像坐在那边跟克里德说话。你能在远处看到他。你知道的，我当时在听DVD评论音轨，格雷格和迈克讨论的一点就是，在这一集里，吉姆和潘几乎不说话。是的。但他们总是出现在彼此镜头的远景或背景中。
That was sort of a conscious thing when they could have one of you in the background they would. That is so interesting because I noticed that in the background of Jim's talking head later, Pam is delivering Phyllis a little piece of candy. Yes. So see, this was thought out. Now there's one other thing I want to point out because in the deleted scenes, Oscar at the top of the episode is handing out Valentine's.
这算是一种刻意的安排，只要有可能把你们其中一人放在背景里，他们就会这么做。这太有趣了，因为我注意到在后来吉姆的单人访谈背景中，潘正在给菲利斯送一小块糖果。是的。所以你看，这是经过深思熟虑的。现在还有一件事我想指出来，因为在被删减片段中，奥斯卡在剧集开头正在分发情人节卡片。
And this is footage behind your talking head. You say, I like Valentine's at this office. We hand out cards and things and you see Oscar passing out these little red hearts. Well, it's a great deleted scene. He hands one to Creed. Creed is getting off the phone where he calls a guy Ace and then he says to Oscar, thanks Ace. And then he has a talking head where he's like, yeah, I'm not good with names.
这就是你单人访谈背后的镜头。你说，我喜欢办公室里的情人节。我们分发卡片和小东西，然后你看到奥斯卡在分发那些红色的小爱心。嗯，这是一个很棒的被删减片段。他递给克里德一个。克里德当时正在打电话，他管电话那头的人叫王牌（Ace），然后他对奥斯卡说，谢啦，王牌。接着他有一个单人访谈，在里面他说，好吧，我不擅长记名字。
I don't know. He like, he doesn't know people's names. So that was actually a scene that then they repurposed and used for the backdrop of your talking head. Oh my gosh. That is a great catch. Yeah. And then I think just before we get into this episode, I would love to give a little
不知道。他就像，他不记得别人的名字。所以这实际上是一个场景，后来被他们重新剪辑并用作你单人访谈的背景。天哪。这真是个绝妙的发现。是的。然后我想在我们正式进入这一集之前，我很想给党建委员会（party planning committee）点个赞，因为你知道的，他们负责办公室的装饰。是的。你看到所有的情人节装饰了吗？我看到了。来自伊齐·加拉金的粉丝发现。她说在大约22秒时，潘的桌上有一个毛绒橄榄球，但我注意到她有情人节主题的糖果。
props to the party planning committee because you know, they were in charge of decorating the office. Yeah. Did you see all the Valentine's stuff? I did. Fan catch from Izzy Garagin. She said around 22 seconds, Pam has a football plush on her desk, but I noticed that she has Valentine's Day themed candy.
她的办公桌上有一个笔筒和一个情人节杯子。而且那些杯子甚至看起来有点像红色的笔。是的。甚至在前台正面还有各种各样的装饰品。她有一个情人节海报，还有一个心形的糖果盘。有红色的果冻豆。果冻豆上面还有一个软乎乎的心形小玩偶。在会计部那边，有心形的花环。
She has a cup of pens and a Valentine's Day cup on the top of her desk. And the cups are even sort of like red pens. Yes. And she even has, there's all these like decorations on the front of reception. She's got like a Valentine's Day poster and there's a heart shaped candy dish. There's red jelly beans. There's like a little squishy heart dude on top of the jelly beans. Over by accounting, there's heart garland.
有一个心形海报。在储物柜那边还有一些心形花环。所以女士们真的是全力以赴了，所谓全力以赴，就是她们贴了两张海报。这仍然在她们的预算之内。但说实话，装饰得还算挺像那么回事的。我也注意到了。好吧。所以接下来，菲利斯收到了一大束玫瑰花。
There's a heart poster. There's some heart garland over on the supply cabinet. So the ladies really, they went all out, by all out, they put up two posters. It's still within their budget. But it was fairly decorated, I will say. I noticed as well. All right. So next up, Phyllis gets a giant bouquet of roses.
你注意到那张卡片了吗？把我逗得哈哈大笑。没有，上面写的什么？花是高级制冷公司的鲍勃·凡斯送的。哦，对。是的。是的。我注意到了。
Did you catch the card? It made me laugh out loud. No, what was it? The flowers are from Bob Vance fan's refrigeration. Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. I did catch that.
没错，就是“高级制冷公司的鲍勃·凡斯”作为卡片内容的一部分。是卡片内容的一部分。是的。这真的让我笑出声来。不知道你们怎么样，反正我丈夫送我礼物时，比如他的卡片功力，宝贝，我爱你。好吧。
Yes. Just that Bob Vance fan's refrigeration was part of the card. Was part of the card. Yes. That does make me laugh. I don't know about you, but my husband, when he gives me a gift, like his card, skills, babe, I love you. Okay.
首先，我很感激他的心意，但对于情人节，他的卡片上写着：致我的妻子，来自你的丈夫，就是那种送花的卡片，非常甜蜜，但卡片上就只有这些。所以我们现在发现迈克尔正前往纽约，向新任首席财务官做关于斯克兰顿分公司情况的简报。我们知道这很重要，因为一直有关于裁员瘦身的传言。所以迈克尔必须真正证明这个分公司的价值，这样才不会有人被解雇。在这场戏里，他收拾好了护照。
First of all, I appreciate the thought, but for Valentine's, his card said, to my wife from your husband, and it was like flowers and it was really sweet, but that's all the card said. So we find out now that Michael is heading to New York to do a presentation about the Scranton branch for the new CFO. And we know this is important because there have been rumors of downsizing. And so Michael has to really prove the worth of this branch so that no one gets fired. In this scene, he packs his passport.
为了两个半小时的车程，伙计们。为了开车。这只是两两个半小时的车程。甚至都不是坐飞机。又不是要过国境线？不用。护照。带上了。
For a two and a half hour drive, guys. For a drive. It's a two and a half hour drive. Not even flying. Not going across the border? Nope. Passport. Got it.
德怀特问他因为今天是情人节，见到简是不是很激动。然后迈克尔有一个单人访谈，在里面他说，我得是个彻头彻尾的疯子才会试图跟简谈论我们之间发生过的事。原话如此。不是我说的。她今天早上给我发了一封电子邮件。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢了。
Dwight asks if he's excited to see Jan because it is Valentine's Day. And then Michael has a talking head where he says, I would have to be a raving lunatic to try to talk to Jan about what happened between us. Her words. Not mine. She sent me an email this morning. I loved that. I loved that so much.
还有，你有没有注意到就在他拿出护照后，德怀特递给他一个看起来像，看起来像黑莓手机的东西？我们这是捕捉到老科技了吗？哦，老科技捕捉。老科技捕捉。我甚至都说不顺溜了。老科技捕捉。
Also, did you notice right after his passport, Dwight hands him what looks like, it looks like a blackberry? Do we have some old tech? Some old tech catch there? Ooh, old tech catch. Old tech catch. I can't even say that. Old tech catch.
老科技捕捉。好吧。当迈克尔离开时，他问潘在纽约能不能给她带点什么。我太喜欢奥斯卡的回答了。因为奥斯卡就像个老爸。他有点像老爸。他就像是，你知道的，最好的礼物就是把简报做好，这样我们大家都能保住工作。
Old tech catch. Okay. As Michael is leaving, he asks Pam if he can pick her up anything in New York. I love Oscar's response. Because Oscar's like the dad. He's kind of the dad. He's like, you know, the best gift would be just do a good job on the presentation so we can all keep our jobs.
对啊。太谢谢了。太谢谢了。而迈克尔却说：我，在纽约？哦，那座城市归我管。别提了。是的。但你得回过头去看看奥斯卡的表情。
Yeah. Thanks a lot. Thanks a lot. And Michael's like, me in New York? Oh, I own that city. Forget about it. Yeah. But you have to go back and look at Oscar's face.
天哪，太精彩了。如果那不是个表情包，那就太可惜了。那必须得是。然后是我们的片头，当片头结束时，迈克尔正开车去纽约。不需要护照。两个半小时的车程。根本不需要。在美利坚合众国境内。
Oh my God, it's so good. If that's not a meme, it should be. That should be. So then we have our opening credits and when those are over, Michael is driving to New York. No need for a passport. Two and a half hour drive. Don't need it. Within the continental United States.
根本不需要。然后吉姆有一个单人访谈，在里面他告诉我们他没有在约会任何人，他只是打算和哥们儿开个派对什么的。好吧，布兰达到底怎么了？我不知道。他谁都没约会。他给布兰达留下了那个极度尴尬的语音留言。我想那没成。
Don't need it. And then Jim has a talking head where he tells us that he is not dating anyone and he's just going to have like a party with his buddies. Well, what the heck happened to Brenda? I don't know. He's not dating anyone. He left Brenda that ridiculously awkward voicemail. I guess that didn't work out.
我想确实没成。现在在单人访谈期间，你还能隐约瞥见潘的婚礼邀请名单。是的。有一个潘坐在办公桌前的镜头，我收到了一个关于它的粉丝提问。好吧，你知道的，我截了图，尽我最大努力去辨认每一个名字。哦，我很想听听都是些什么名字。路易莎·J问，婚礼邀请名单上的名字是角色名字、虚构的名字还是以现实生活中的人为基础的？
I guess it didn't. Now during his talking head, you can kind of get a glimpse at Pam's wedding invite list. Yeah. There's a shot of Pam at her desk and I had a fan question about it. Okay, you know, I did a screen grab and tried my best to read every name. Oh, I want to hear what they are. Louisa J said, are the names on the wedding invite list characters or made up or based on real life people?
我当时在看其中一些名字，部分看起来，就像可能是菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）起草了这份名单，但看起来你在这一场戏里又往上面添了名字。是的。打印好的名单是菲尔·谢伊提供给我的。是的。打印好的名单上是我真正的姨妈、叔叔和表亲的名字。我正想说，我看到了艾米丽（Emily），那是你姐姐的名字。没错。
Now I was looking at some of these names and part of it looked like, like maybe Phil Shea had started the list, but it looked like you had added to it during the scene. Yes. The typed list was provided to me by Phil Shea. Yes. The typed list are the names of my real aunts and uncles and cousins. I was going to say, I saw Emily, which is your sister. Yep.
所以我当时想，当我截屏的时候，我心想，哦，珍娜只是开始写她真正的家人了。我确实写了。好吧。我想也是。是的。我写下了鲍勃和米莉，吉姆和黛比，埃德，对，你写了埃德，马克，吉姆和黛比。
So I was like, as I screen grabbed it, I was like, oh, Jenna just started writing her actual family. I did. Okay. That's what I thought. Yeah. I wrote down Bob and Millie, Jim and Debbie, Ed, yeah, you wrote down Ed, Mark, Jim and Debbie.
看起来还有安（Anne），那是你妈妈的名字。那是我妈妈。对。对。好吧。所以我们是怎么在电视上看到他们的名字的？不，我觉得这太棒了。我也会这么做的。
It looked like Anne, which is your mom's name. That's my mom. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So how do we get to see their names on TV? No, I think that's fantastic. I would have done the same thing.
我很确信我叔叔鲍勃确实给我发了一电子邮件，因为他注意到了，或者有人注意到并告诉了他。所以这就像是一个有趣的小花絮。我觉得也挺好，因为你们家的人名都还挺大众化的，因为就像我也会这么做，但我的名单看起来会像是：伯蒂，我阿姨塞尔玛。就像会变成：等等，这，这份名单看起来有点南方特色。我们来看看。接下来德怀特收到了一份情人节礼物。
I'm pretty sure my uncle Bob did write me an email because he noticed or someone noticed and told him. So that was like a fun little thing. I think it's also good that your family has somewhat like common names because like I would have done the same thing, but my list would have been like Birdie, my Aunt Thelma. Like it'd be like, wait, this, this list looks a little Southern. Let's see. Next up Dwight gets a Valentine's Day gift.
哦，他桌上有个盒子。他得到了有史以来最好的礼物。是的。他得到了一个德怀特摇头娃娃，一个他自己的摇头娃娃。我们有一个粉丝提问。实际上，很多人都问了，但芝加哥的凯莉·佩克和恩扎都问了：德怀特摇头娃娃是怎么制作的？所以菲尔·谢伊在网上找到了一个摇头娃娃制作商，他让雷恩摆好姿势拍照片，
Oh, there's a box on his desk. He gets the best gift ever. Yes. He gets a Dwight bobblehead, a bobblehead of himself. And we had a fan question. Actually, a lot of people asked, but Kelly Peck and Enza from Chicago both asked, how was the Dwight bobblehead made? So Phil Shea found a bobblehead maker on the internet and he had rain posed for pictures
穿着他的德怀特服装，他们从各个方向给他拍照。全方位。是的。然后把照片发过去。花了好几个星期，他们寄回了一个样品。他们能够做一些修改备注，然后他们寄出了真正的成品，而且他们只寄了这一个家伙。我还记得成品其实也挺脆弱的。
in his Dwight outfit and they took pictures of him from all directions. All angles. Yes. And sent them in. It took a couple of weeks and they sent back a sample. They were able to make notes and then they sent the real thing and they just sent the one guy. I remember the real thing too was kind of fragile.
是的，而且很重。很重。很重。它不像你现在在网上能买到的那些。它不是塑料做的。如果你想给自己做一个，那个人现在还在做呢。啊，他叫什么名字？
Yeah. And it was heavy. Heavy. Heavy. It's not like the ones you can buy now online. It's not made out of plastic. And if you want one of yourself, the guy's still making them. Aw, what's his name?
我们给他打个广告吧。是bobblemaker.com。Bobblemaker.com制作了最初的德怀特摇头娃娃。没错。它最初的名字叫“你缩小了”（It's You Small）。我喜欢这个名字。“你缩小了”。
Let's give him a shout out. It's bobblemaker.com. Bobblemaker.com made the original Dwight bobblehead. That's right. And it was originally called It's You Small. It's You Small. I like that. It's You Small.
但没错，bobblemaker.com。你可以在那里定制一个你自己的摇头娃娃，我上去看了一眼，它们真的很棒。你还可以为你家的宠物、你的全家人定制。你也可以只把你的脸雕刻下来，然后把它放到一个咖啡马克杯上，就像是从咖啡马克杯里钻出来一样。那个我就没那么感兴趣了。我实话实说。
But yeah, bobblemaker.com. That's where you can get a bobblehead made of yourself and I went on there and they're really great. You can also get them made of your pets, your whole family. You'll also just sculpt your face and put it on a coffee mug, like coming out of a coffee mug. That one I wasn't quite as attracted to. I'm going to just be honest.
一个生出你脸的咖啡马克杯？对。但摇头娃娃太棒了。我其实挺想要一个我们家猫奥利奥的摇头娃娃的。我对桑尼也有同感。哦，我们应该去弄猫咪摇头娃娃。我想要一个猫咪摇头娃娃。好吧，我们聊到哪儿了？
The coffee mug giving birth to your face? Yeah. But the bobbleheads are amazing. I would kind of like a bobblehead of our cat Oreo. I thought the same thing about Sunny. Oh, we should get kitty cat bobbleheads. I want a kitty cat bobblehead. Okay, where are we?
我关于摇头娃娃还有达格玛拉·K的一个问题。最后有人把德怀特的摇头娃娃留作纪念了吗？嗯，我当时以为雷恩把它留下了，所以我发信息问他，他说没有。那是谁留下的？全国广播公司（NBC）。等剧集结束时他们把它拿去拍卖了。哦，这让我有点难过。这也让我有点难过。
I had another question about the bobblehead from Dagmara K. Did anyone end up keeping Dwight's bobblehead? Well, I just assumed that Rain got to keep it, so I texted him and he said no. Who kept it? NBC. And they auctioned it off when the series ended. Oh, that makes me a little sad. It makes me a little sad too.
我还有一个关于Dagmara K.提出的摇头娃娃的问题。最后有人把德怀特的摇头娃娃留下来了吗？嗯，我本来以为雷恩会留着它，所以我发短信问他，他说没有。那是谁留下的？NBC。剧集结束时他们把它拍卖了。哦，这让我有点难过。我也觉得有点难过。
And it brought up a question for me. I remember NBC did this big auction of all our stuff. They auctioned off some of our clothes. Oh, there was a big auction. I think they auctioned off all the desks and furniture. A bunch of stuff from the desks, a bunch of furniture, but it made me wonder with all this talk and speculation about a possible reboot, how do they get all the stuff back? How do they even recreate the set if they auctioned everything off?
这让我产生了一个疑问。我记得NBC曾对我们的所有物品进行过一次大型拍卖。他们拍卖了我们的一些衣服。哦，当时有一场很大的拍卖。我想他们把所有的办公桌和家具都拍卖了。办公桌里的很多东西，还有一大堆家具，但它让我感到好奇，既然有这么多关于重启节目的讨论和猜测，他们是怎么把所有东西拿回来的呢？如果他们把一切都拍卖了，他们甚至要怎么重建布景？
Well, I think that probably doesn't bode well for a reboot. I think that people are like, nope. They'll have to, you know, get bobblemaker.com to make another bobblehead. I guess. I don't know. I actually have a Dwight and Angela bobblehead, and I bought one and Rain signed it for me. So I have a signed Rain bobblehead. After this episode, people started asking for Dwight bobbleheads, and so NBC made a run
嗯，我觉得这可能对重启节目不是个好兆头。我觉得大家会觉得，没门。你知道的，他们只能去找bobblemaker.com再做一个摇头娃娃了。我猜的。我也不知道。其实我有一个德怀特和安吉拉的摇头娃娃，我买了一个，雷恩还给我签了名。所以我有一个签了名的雷恩摇头娃娃。这集播出后，大家开始要求推出德怀特的摇头娃娃，于是NBC就制作了一批
of bobbleheads. They found a way to make them. Mass produce them. Yes. Yeah. And they sold out immediately. All right. So next up in the episode, Michael is walking the streets of New York.
摇头娃娃。他们找到了制作的方法。批量生产它们。是的。对的。而且它们一经推出就售罄了。好的。那么接下来在这集中，迈克尔正走在纽约的街道上。
Oh, he's so happy. Oh, he walks by his favorite local New York pizza joint, Sabaro. You can only find it in New York. It's such a great joke because you guys know Sabaro is a huge chain, you can get it outside of New York City. However, this made me curious about Sabaro, so guess what I found out. What'd you find out, lady? Let me tell you, Sabaro began in 1956 when Carmella and Genaro Sabaro opened an Italian
哦，他太开心了。哦，他走过他最喜欢的纽约本地披萨店，萨巴罗。你只能在纽约找到它。这是一个非常棒的笑话，因为大家都知道萨巴罗是个大连锁店，你在纽约市以外也能吃到。不过，这让我对萨巴罗产生了好奇，所以你猜我发现了什么。你发现了什么，女士？让我告诉你，萨巴罗始创于1956年，当时卡梅拉和热纳罗·萨巴罗在布鲁克林开了一家意大利
grocery store in Brooklyn that also happened to sell food. Okay. So they had a little deli. They had a little market. Yes. And one of the things that they sold was pizza by the slice. Mama Sabaro, as she was known, had this pizza by the slice, and it became super popular with construction workers, shift workers who needed to grab something in one hand and eat
杂货店，这家店顺便也卖吃的。好的。所以他们有一个小熟食柜台。他们有一个小市场。是的。他们卖的东西之一就是按片卖的披萨。人们熟知的萨巴罗妈妈推出了这种按片卖的披萨，它在建筑工人和轮班工人中变得超级受欢迎，因为他们需要一只手拿东西吃，
on the go. They became so popular that they ended up opening a second location that was only about pizza. Okay. Pizza only. We are not sponsored by Spar- We are not. Spar-bar-ro.
边走边吃。它们变得如此受欢迎，以至于最后他们开了一家只卖披萨的第二家分店。好的。只卖披萨。我们没有赞助商-我们没有。S-bar-ro。
Probably because I can't say it. Spar-bar-ro? Sabaro. Sabaro. Not Spar-bar-ro. Not Spar-bar-ro. That's a different restaurant. Sabaro.
可能因为我不会发音。S-bar-ro？萨巴罗。萨巴罗。不是S-bar-ro。不是S-bar-ro。那是另一家餐厅。萨巴罗。
Sabaro. And so since then, though, Sabaro has expanded into 630 eateries across 28 countries. I'm applauding you. Spar-bar-ro. So on their website, it says, quote, you're welcome, world. Well, well, not only pizza slices, but pizza slices with sass. I like it. That's some Sabaro sass.
萨巴罗。不过从那以后，萨巴罗已经扩展到28个国家的630家餐厅。我为你鼓掌。S-bar-ro。所以在他们的官网上，写着“不用谢，全世界”。哇，不仅有单片披萨，还有带点个性的单片披萨。我喜欢。这就是萨巴罗的个性。
That's some Sbar-ro sass. But I thought it was interesting because the joke of our episode is kind of that Michael doesn't get what a local pizza joint is, but it did actually start as a local pizza joint. It did start local. It did start local. Just not in Times Square. So there you go. So next we go back to the office and Jim and Kelly are in the kitchen.
这就是萨巴罗的个性。但我觉得很有趣，因为我们这一集的笑话有点像迈克尔根本不懂什么是本地披萨店，但它其实真的是作为一家本地披萨店起家的。它的确是本地起家的。它的确是本地起家的。只是不在时代广场。所以就是这样。接下来我们回到办公室，吉姆和凯利在厨房里。
I love this scene so much. John Krasinski, you're acting in this scene as delicious. It's delicious. Mindy's acting is delicious. So good. It's like, she's so funny in it. She's full on Mindy. Yeah, it's full Mindy.
我太喜欢这个场景了。约翰·卡拉辛斯基，你在这个场景里的演技太棒了。太棒了。明迪的演技太棒了。太好了。就好像，她在里面太搞笑了。她完全就是明迪。对，完全是明迪。
This is full Mindy. I want you to know when I was listening to the DVD commentary, I almost like spit out like who the water I was drinking because Greg and Mike both go, oh, I mean, Mindy just took over. Like, there's no more Kelly. It's just Mindy. This was a whole thing. Yeah.
这就是纯粹的明迪。我想让你们知道，当我听DVD评论音轨时，我差点把我喝的水像……谁一样喷出来，因为格雷格和迈克都说，“哦，我是说，明迪直接接管了。”就好像，没有凯利了。只有明迪。这整件事就是这样。对。
What they don't know is that it happened last episode. Okay. Well, I felt very validated that we didn't even know that like they totally talk about it in the commentary. That's amazing. Well, basically she tells Jim that her and Ryan hooked up last night. Yes. And Mindy says in the DVD commentary, she goes, Mike, I really feel like this scene is just
他们不知道的是，上一集就发生了。好吧，我觉得非常欣慰，我们甚至不知道他们完全在评论音轨里谈论了这个。太棒了。好吧，基本上她告诉吉姆，她和瑞恩昨晚勾搭上了。是的。明迪在DVD评论音轨里说，她说：“迈克，我真的觉得这个场景就像是你和我实际关于一个男人的对话的逐字稿，”这让我笑喷了。好吧，这就引出了那个非常著名的瑞恩面对镜头的独白。我在2月13日和她勾搭上了。我知道。
like a transcription of a conversation you and I actually had about a guy, which cracked me up. Well, it leads to the very famous Ryan talking head. I hooked up with her on February 13th. I know. It was like so perfect. All right. So then we head back to New York City again and now we're going to see Michael in Times
这简直太完美了。好了，然后我们再次回到纽约市，现在我们要看迈克尔在时代
Square. You know, a lot of people, he tells you they get to New York and they go to really touristy places like the Empire State Building, but he likes to go to Times Square. He likes to go to the most tourist spot in New York, which I love. And then at five minutes, 26 seconds, Michael is giving us a tour of Rockefeller Center. Yes. And he says, found it, of course, by Theodore Rockefeller. And he also says that the Rangers sometimes practice there.
广场。你知道，很多人，他告诉你，他们到了纽约，会去一些非常游客化的地方，比如帝国大厦，但他喜欢去时代广场。他喜欢去纽约游客最多的地方，我太喜欢这样了。然后在5分钟26秒时，迈克尔在给我们介绍洛克菲勒中心。是的。他说，当然是由西奥多·洛克菲勒创立的。他还说流浪者队有时会在那里练习。
Okay. I did a deep dive. The Rangers don't practice there. The Rangers don't practice there, but they do sometimes practice at this rink in Central Park. Like once a year, there's a rink there. I know this because I have a huge hockey, yeah, I'm a hockey mom. Your husband plays hockey.
好吧。我做了一番深入研究。流浪者队不在那里练习。流浪者队不在那里练习，但他们确实有时会在中央公园的这个冰场练习。一年大约有一次，那里有一个冰场。我知道这一点，是因为我是一个超级冰球迷，对，我是一个冰球妈妈。你丈夫打冰球。
Your son plays hockey. You're a hockey mom. Yes. And that's when the Rangers have practiced on this rink in Central Park and it's super cool. It's a thing they do for the fans, but never at Rockefeller Center. Also, there is no one named Theodore Rockefeller. I did a deep dive on the Rockefeller family and I could not find anyone named Theodore.
你儿子打冰球。你是一个冰球妈妈。是的。这就是流浪者队在这个中央公园的冰场练习的时候，酷极了。这是他们为球迷做的一件事，但绝对不是在洛克菲勒中心。此外，也没有叫西奥多·洛克菲勒的人。我对洛克菲勒家族做了一番深入研究，根本找不到任何叫西奥多的人。
Okay. I know 30 Rock really well because I worked there. Oh, that's right. I was an intern on the Conan O'Brien show. And so were like a bunch of office people. Mindy, Ellie, John. But not at the same time. I'm much older than those guys.
好吧。我对30号洛克菲勒大厦非常熟悉，因为我在那工作过。哦，对哦。我是柯南·奥布莱恩秀的实习生。办公室里的一群人也是。明迪、埃莉、约翰。但不是同一时间。我比那些家伙大得多。
I was there the very first year of Conan when they thought they were going to get canceled week to week. Oh my gosh. What do you do when you're an intern on that? What is that? Well, there was... What does that mean? Well, there was different types of internships.
我在柯南的第一年就在那里了，当时他们以为每周都面临被砍节目的危险。天哪。当那里的实习生是做什么的？那是什么？嗯，有……那是什么意思？嗯，有不同类型的实习生。
There was a writer's intern. So when I got the internship, they already had the writer's intern. So I became a general intern. So I just basically got everyone their coffee and I didn't know New York City, so I kept getting lost. It was probably the worst coffee run person ever. Did you get to meet Conan or interact with him as an intern? I didn't.
有编剧实习生。所以我得到实习机会时，他们已经有编剧实习生了。所以我成了一名普通实习生。所以基本上我就是去给大家买咖啡，而且我对纽约市不熟，所以我一直迷路。我可能是史上最糟糕的跑腿买咖啡的人了。你作为实习生有机会见到柯南或与他互动吗？我没有。
And I mean, he would walk past and he was always nice. He would kind of give a nod or away, but he was busy. You know? Yeah. And I knew not to bug him. Like I had enough awareness that I wasn't going to be like, hey, Conan, I'm the new intern. What you doing? The really cool thing about Conan Studio is it was one floor away from where they did
我的意思是，他会走过去，而且他总是很友好。他会点头或挥手，但他很忙。你知道吗？对。而且我知道不要去打扰他。我有足够的自觉性，不会去说：“嘿，柯南，我是新来的实习生。你在干嘛？”柯南工作室最酷的一点是，它离他们制作
Saturday Night Live. So could you... You could do a backdoor... Like watch SNL ever? I actually... One of the people that worked on Conan knew that I was pretty strapped for cash and she got me a weekend job on Saturday Night Live as an extra. So there's a whole season of SNL that I'm an extra and I'm in a bunch of skits.
《周六夜现场》只有一层楼的距离。所以你能……你能走后门……比如看过SNL吗？其实……柯南的一个工作人员知道我手头非常紧，她在《周六夜现场》给我安排了一份周末群演的工作。所以有一整季的SNL里我都是群演，我在好几个小品里出现过。
What? Yes. There's a great scene with Chris Farley and I'm like sitting in front of him and everyone was so nice. Yeah. Because all that stuff is happening in that same building. Yeah. That's what's so crazy about that area.
什么？是的。有一个克里斯·法利参与的精彩场景，我好像就坐在他前面，每个人都超级好。对。因为所有这些事情都在同一栋大楼里发生。对。这正是那个地区最疯狂的地方。
And NBC News is happening in the Today Show. It's all right there. Can I tell you one of the coolest moments is right outside the stage doors where we recorded. I'm standing in this hallway alone. There's no one in the hallway. The elevator doors open and Robert Redford walked out. Wow. And he was with like an NBC, someone in a suit and they were walking down the hall and they
而且NBC新闻和《今日秀》也都在那里。它就在那里。我能告诉你最酷的时刻之一是什么吗？就在我们录制节目的舞台门外。我独自站在这个走廊里。走廊里空无一人。电梯门开了，罗伯特·雷德福走了出来。哇。他和一个NBC的人，一个穿西装的人在一起，他们沿着走廊走过来，
just walked past me and I was just like... Just watched Robert Redford walk right by. Wow. I'm just like a young kid from middle of nowhere, Texas. It was just like a really cool surreal moment. And there were many of those in my time there. That is pretty awesome. So we got a lot of fan questions about this Tina Fey Conan O'Brien business.
他们就从我身边走过，我当时就……只是看着罗伯特·雷德福从旁边走过。哇。我只是一个来自德克萨斯州偏远乡下的年轻孩子。这真是一个非常酷、超现实的时刻。在我那段经历中，有很多这样的时刻。这真是太棒了。所以我们收到了很多关于蒂娜·菲和柯南·奥布莱恩事件的粉丝提问。
The first one is from Sarah Marshall 44. Did production hire the woman to play the fake Tina Fey or was she just a random person? No. We hired her. She is an actress named Miriam Tolan. She's been in a ton of stuff, including ironically an episode of 30 Rock Season 2, Episode 14. She has a really funny scene with Jason Satekis around 12 minutes. She plays a woman at a check-in counter at an airline.
第一个问题来自Sarah Marshall 44。制作团队是雇佣演员来扮演假蒂娜·菲，还是她只是个路人？不。我们雇佣了她。她是一位名叫米里亚姆·托兰的女演员。她演过成吨的作品，包括具有讽刺意味的《我为喜剧狂》第二季第14集。她在12分钟左右与杰森·苏戴奇斯有一场非常搞笑的戏。她饰演航空公司值机柜台的一名女性。
It's very funny. I went back and watched the whole episode. Oh, I want to see it. I want to see it. It's really good. And then we had another fan question from Livy Fitzgerald. Please explain the Conan cameo. Well, you know Greg and Conan were very good friends.
非常搞笑。我回去把整集都看了一遍。哦，我想看。我想看。真的很棒。然后我们收到了利维·菲茨杰拉德的另一个粉丝提问。请解释一下柯南的客串。嗯，你知道格雷格和柯南是很好的朋友。
They went to college together. They were roommates. I think some of their very early writing jobs on SNL and Simpsons, they lived together. They're friends. They're really good friends. And so it definitely makes sense that Greg would want to reach out to Conan if he was right there. There is quite a bit about it in the DVD commentary, but one of the things that really stuck with
他们一起上大学。他们曾是室友。我想他们在SNL和辛普森一家的一些早期编剧工作时，他们住在一起。他们是朋友。他们是非常好的朋友。所以如果柯南就在附近，格雷格想联系他绝对是合情合理的。DVD评论音轨里有很多关于这的内容，但其中一件事真正触动了
me that I loved is that Greg said it took Conan 15 takes to time that out. He said literally it took about 15 tries and he said, you think Steve gets a big crowd? Even Conan standing in front of the building where they tape Conan. Yeah. He said the crowds were crazy, so they were trying to get that. And he's really tall. He's incredibly tall. He has red hair.
我并且我非常喜欢的是，格雷格说柯南花了15条才把时间掐准。他说字面意思上他们尝试了大约15次，他说，“你觉得史蒂夫能吸引一大群人吗？”甚至连柯南站在录制柯南节目的那栋大楼前面时也是如此。对。他说人群太疯狂了，所以他们一直在努力拍摄那个镜头。而且他真的很高。他高得不可思议。他有一头红发。
He's very, very distinguishable. Hard to blend. Hard to blend. Mike sure said that he wrote the scene with fake Tina Fey as a shout out to her, a little nod to their time together on Saturday Night Live, because he said tourists were constantly mistaking other women with brown hair and glasses for Tina Fey. It was almost like a joke. They would watch other women get tapped on the shoulder and it was never Tina Fey.
他非常非常显眼。很难融入人群。很难融入。迈克确实说过，他写假蒂娜·菲这个场景是为了向她致敬，对他们在《周六夜现场》共事时光的小小敬意，因为他说游客经常把其他留着棕色头发戴眼镜的女性误认为蒂娜·菲。这几乎成了一个笑话。他们会看着其他女性被人拍肩膀，但那从来都不是蒂娜·菲。
And he said that many times him and Tina would take a coffee break in between writing and walk outside and no one would stop her. No one would stop the real Tina Fey. No one would stop the real Tina Fey, but they would mistake all these other women. And so he said that scene was kind of his little nod to Tina. Oh my gosh. I love that. I did too.
而且他说很多次他和蒂娜在写作间隙喝咖啡休息时走出去，没有人会拦住她。没有人会拦住真正的蒂娜·菲。没有人会拦住真正的蒂娜·菲，但他们会认错所有这些其他的女性。所以他说那个场景算是他对蒂娜的小小致敬。天哪。我太喜欢了。我也是。
I love that. All right. So next we go back into the office and more flowers arrive for Phyllis. Oh gosh. From Bob Vance. I mean Bob Vance. Not for Pam. They're for Phyllis.
我太喜欢了。好的。接下来我们回到办公室，菲莉丝收到了更多的鲜花。哦，天哪。来自鲍勃·万斯。我是说鲍勃·万斯。不是给帕姆的。是给菲莉丝的。
Pam is getting annoyed. And you know who else is taking it hard? Meredith. Meredith. She's taking it real hard. She's looking real sour. Yeah. Well, then we have this awesome covert scene between Dwight and Angela at the copier.
帕姆开始生气了。你们知道还有谁对此很难受吗？梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思。她真的很难受。她看起来脸色非常难看。对。好吧，接着德怀特和安吉拉在复印机旁有一场非常棒的秘密谈话。
Yes. And he says, thank you for the gift. And then she says, I haven't gotten one yet. I haven't gotten anything. No. Now this has nothing to do with the scene, but I have to bring it up right now because this is the first moment you really get a full shot of me, right on camera. Yeah.
是的。他说：“谢谢你的礼物。”然后她说：“我还没收到呢。我什么都没收到。不。”现在这和这个场景完全无关，但我现在必须提出来，因为这是你真正第一次在镜头前看到我的完整特写镜头，对吧？对。
Do I look tan, Jenna? Do I look a little tan? Yes. Now that you mention it. Oh, I am very tan because in my journal you guys, I wrote, we shot. This during the Golden Globes when I got that mystic spray tan. Oh, that's right. When we went to the Golden Globes, when Steve won, yeah, you got a spray tan that was real
我看起来黑吗，珍娜？我看起来有点黑吗？对。经你这么一提起。哦，我很黑，因为你们知道，我在日记里写了，我们拍摄。这个的时候正值金球奖期间，当时我做了那个神秘喷雾美黑。哦，对哦。当我们去金球奖时，史蒂夫获奖的那次，对，你做了一个非常黑的喷雾美黑。
dark. It was orange. Guys, I watched this episode in the next one. I am like orange for two weeks. Oh my gosh. I mean, I am so tan. It's ridiculous. And they tried to like make my face look lighter.
是橘色的。伙计们，我看这一集和下一集。我大概黑了两个星期。天哪。我的意思是，我黑得太厉害了。太荒谬了。他们试图让我的脸看起来浅一点。
Like I wrote it to tone it down. I wrote about it in my journal that they tried to tone down my tan. But what happened was my, it just, I just look weird. I thought you looked good in this episode. Well, I'm, I have a mystic tan. Oh. A spray tan. But anyway, when I watched that scene, all I could see was my very, very tan forehead.
就像我写的那样为了把它调淡。我在日记里写过，他们试图淡化我的美黑。但结果是我的，它只是，我看起来很怪异。我觉得你在这一集里看起来很好看。好吧，我有神秘美黑。哦。喷雾美黑。不过总之，当我看到那个场景时，我能看到的只有我非常非常黑的额头。
And next to rain, I look crazy tan because he's so white. Um, but yes, I have given Dwight, he says the best gift ever. Yeah. He promises that he has one for me, which I'm very happy about. And then he clearly realizes, oh no, now I have to deliver. Exactly. Exactly. He says, you'll get something by the end of today.
站在雷恩旁边，我看起来黑得发疯，因为他太白了。嗯，但是是的，我已经送给德怀特了，他说这是史上最好的礼物。对。他承诺他也会给我准备一个，我对此非常高兴。然后他显然意识到，“哦不，现在我得兑现了。”没毛病。没毛病。他说：“你今天结束前会收到东西的。”
He needs to give himself some time. Yeah. To get something. All right. So then we have the scene where Jim is on the phone. He's making plans with his poker buddies. John Krasinski does such great fake phone. You guys.
他需要给自己留点时间。对。去弄个礼物。好的。接下来就是吉姆在打电话的场景。他在和他的扑克牌友们做计划。约翰·卡拉辛斯基的假打电话演得太棒了。伙计们。
Fake phone. It's not easy. No, there's no one on the other end of that call. I fully believed he's talking to someone and his laugh seems so organic. Yeah. I'm like, John, applause for fake phone skills. Great fake phone. Really, really good.
假打电话。这可不容易。对，电话那头根本没有人。我完全相信他在跟某人说话，而且他的笑声看起来那么自然。对。我心里想，约翰，为你假打电话的演技鼓掌。演得太棒了。真的非常非常棒。
And this is also sort of the time in their relationship, if you will, where Jim, I mean, you have a wedding date set. Yeah. It's like all that Pam is talking about really is like planning the wedding and Jim really starts to pull away and then you see Pam feeling that absence. Well, and remember in the last episode, they got in a full fight. Yeah. About Pam's decision to not pursue her graphic design internship.
这也是他们感情中，如果你愿意这么说的话，吉姆开始……我的意思是，你们已经定好了婚礼日期。对。帕姆谈论的基本上全是筹备婚礼，而吉姆真的开始抽身离去，然后你会看到帕姆感受到了那种缺席。嗯，还记得上一集里，他们大吵了一架。对。关于帕姆决定放弃追求她的平面设计实习机会。
Yeah. And so I think Jim kind of feels like, I don't know what I'm supposed to do here. I don't know where I fit in anymore. Yeah. And she's getting married. Yeah. Yeah. And then a giant teddy bear arrives and it's being delivered by two guys in Vance refrigeration
对。所以我觉得吉姆有点觉得，“我不知道我在这里该做什么。我不知道我还能否融入这里。”对。而她要结婚了。对。对。然后一个巨大的泰迪熊送到了，是由两个穿着万斯制冷公司服装的人送来的。
outfits. They were played by our writing team of Jean Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, but you only see Jean. Lee got cut out. Lee got cut out. It's in the deleted scene. Yeah. They get in a fist fight.
他们由我们的编剧团队吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格扮演，但你只能看到吉恩。李被剪掉了。李被剪掉了。在删减片段里。对。他们打了一架。
Yeah. It's kind of ridiculous. But Jean is the person who says Phyllis Lappin. So if you're wondering which one is Jean and which one is Lee, Jean is in this episode. And they come back later. They're going to recur and you'll actually get to see Lee. There's a very funny little sort of exchange between Jean and Brian as Kevin, where Kevin's like, that thing's as big as me and Jean's like, no, it's not.
对。有点荒谬。但吉恩是那个说出“菲莉丝·拉平”的人。所以如果你想知道哪个是吉恩哪个是李，吉恩在这集里。他们后来还会回来。他们会再次出场，你到时候就能看到李了。吉恩和作为凯文的布莱恩之间有一段非常搞笑的小对话，凯文说：“那东西跟我一样大，”吉恩说：“不，它没有。”
No, it's not. Kevin's like, zip it. So now Michael has finally made it to his meeting. He's done wandering the streets of New York and he's going to meet with the other branch managers in a conference room. And I just want to mention, we said this earlier, this part of it was not shot in New York. This was shot on some stages. Right there where we film every day in California.
不，它没有。凯文说：“闭嘴。”现在迈克尔终于到了他的会议地点。他结束了在纽约街头的闲逛，他要去会议室和其他分公司经理会面。我想提一下，我们之前说过，这部分不是在纽约拍摄的。这是在一些布景里拍的。就在我们在加州每天拍摄的地方。
Yes. Look out the window. They did such a good job. The backdrop, it really looks like they're up high in a building in New York. No, they're, the trickery is so good. Our set design team was phenomenal. Yeah. But really they are on ground level in a warehouse in a set.
是的。看窗外。他们做得太棒了。背景看起来真的很像他们在纽约某栋大楼的高层。不，他们，视觉把戏太棒了。我们的布景设计团队太出色了。对。但实际上他们是在一个仓库的摄影棚里。
In Van Nuys, California. Yeah. Yeah. Kind of amazing. But let's meet the other managers. Yes. I have a card. All right.
在加利福尼亚州的凡奈斯。对。对。简直太神奇了。但让我们去见见其他经理。是的。我有一张名片。好的。
Give me your card, lady. Here's my card. So the other managers are Dan Gore, who manages Buffalo. Yes. Played by Dan Cole. Josh Porter. He manages Stamford Branch. Craig.
把你的名片给我，女士。这是我的名片。其他经理有丹·戈尔，他管理布法罗分公司。是的。由丹·科尔饰演。乔什·波特。他管理斯坦福分公司。克雷格。
Michael calls them Craigers. Played by Craig Anton. Manages Albany. Yes. So here's a little tidbit about the Dan Gore character. Okay. In the DVD commentary, Mike sure says the quiet guy in the conference room he named after his good friend, Dan Gore.
迈克尔管他们叫克雷格。由克雷格·安东饰演。管理奥尔巴尼。是的。这里有个关于丹·戈尔这个角色的花絮。好的。在DVD评论音轨里，迈克·舒尔说会议室里那个安静的家伙是以他的好朋友丹·戈尔的名字命名的。
The writer, Dan Gore. Oh, yeah. Dan Gore, who, I mean, he created Brooklyn Nine-Nine. He's a phenomenal writer. Yeah. And he was a friend of Mike's. And Mindy sort of chimed in that Mike loved to do that. He loved to put his friends' names in things.
编剧丹·戈尔。哦，对。丹·戈尔，我的意思是，他创作了《神烦警探》。他是个了不起的编剧。对。他是迈克的朋。明迪插话说是迈克很喜欢这么做。他很喜欢把朋友的名字放进各种东西里。
He was a Conan writer. He wrote on Parks and Rec. And now, of course, he's the showrunner of Brooklyn Nine-Nine. So Dan Gore got a nice little shout out in this episode. Yes. He's meeting all the branch heads. And Craigers is an idiot. He's right.
他是《柯南秀》的编剧。他为《公园与游憩》写过剧本。现在，当然，他是《神烦警探》的制片人。所以丹·戈尔在这集里得到了一个不错的小致敬。是的。他正在见所有的分公司主管。而克雷格是个白痴。他说得对。
He's gotten kicked out of all the strip clubs in Albany. Very proud of that. We find out. And then he starts insulting Jan. Yeah. Yeah. He calls her the B word. He does.
他被奥尔巴尼所有的脱衣舞俱乐部赶出来了。对此感到非常骄傲。我们了解到这一点。然后他开始侮辱简。对。对。他用了那个B开头的词。他确实用了。
And Michael comes to her defense. He says, oh, come on now, come on now. And he stands up for her first by saying, that's my girlfriend, boy. And then he backpedals and says, I mean, we hooked up. And then Josh Porter's like, you hooked up with Jan? And now, he's in it. He's spilled the beans. Dang it, Michael.
而迈克尔为她辩护。他说：“哦，得了吧，得了吧。”他首先站出来为她辩护说：“那是我的女朋友，老兄。”然后他又改口说：“我是说，我们勾搭过。”接着乔什·波特说：“你跟简勾搭过？”现在，他入局了。他把秘密全抖出来了。该死，迈克尔。
Michael. He's only been there like five minutes. Yeah. He's been in a room with these people for five minutes and he's already told everyone that he's hooked up with Jan. With their boss. Yeah. Oh, Michael.
迈克尔。他才刚到那儿大概五分钟。对。他在一个房间里跟这群人待了五分钟，就已经告诉了所有人他跟简勾搭过。和他们的老板。哦，迈克尔。
And then it's like crickets in the room. All right. Well, maybe we should take a break. Yeah. With that, with that news. On that news, Michael has just spilled the beans and we'll be right back. Because one of my favorite scenes is happening back at the office. Yeah.
然后房间里鸦雀无声。好吧，也许我们该休息一下。对。带着这个，带着这个消息。带着这个消息，迈克尔刚刚把秘密抖了出来，我们马上回来。因为我最喜欢的场景之一马上要在办公室上演了。对。
We need to talk about it. It's good stuff. It's good. Okay. So we're back. You guys, I have to talk about this scene between Dwight and Pam in the break room. Yeah. I loved it so much, Jenna.
我们得聊聊这个。这是好东西。很好。好吧，我们回来了。伙计们，我必须聊聊德怀特和帕姆在茶水间的这个场景。对。我太喜欢了，珍娜。
I rewound and watched it a few times. Oh, gosh, how did you get through it without laughing? You know, your reaction when he says, like a ham, and you're like, no, not exactly like a ham. Jenna, it's so funny. I don't even know how you kept straight face though. My intention in that was like I was talking to like a five or a six year old and I couldn't let them see my real feelings about the things they were saying.
我倒回去看了好几遍。哦，天哪，你是怎么忍住不笑场拍完的？你知道当你听到他说“像火腿一样”时你的反应，你说：“不，不完全像火腿。”珍娜，太搞笑了。我甚至不知道你是怎么保持严肃表情的。我当时的意图就好像我在跟一个五六岁的小孩说话，我不能让他们看出我对他们说的话的真实感受。
Yeah. Exactly. We had a fan question from SusieYoung22. She wanted to know if like a ham was scripted or improvised. It was improvised. Did he improvise a bunch? Yeah. So on the day, we didn't really have an ending to this scene.
对。完全如此。我们收到了来自苏茜杨22的一个粉丝提问。她想知道“像火腿一样”是剧本里的台词还是即兴发挥。是即兴发挥的。他即兴发挥了很多吗？是的。所以在拍摄当天，我们其实没有给这个场景安排结尾。
Okay. We had him coming in and asking for advice and they wanted a button and this would often happen in scenes and the writers would then come over and give us a list of options. Like suggestions. Yeah. So like a ham was improvised, but then there were all these other options that were written on a piece of paper and so we shot all of these things that he said like like a this, like a that, like this, like that.
好吧。我们拍了他进来寻求建议，然后他们需要一个笑点，这种事在拍戏时经常发生，然后编剧们就会过来给我们提供一堆选项。比如建议。对。所以像火腿一样是即兴发挥的，但当时纸上写着所有这些其他的选项，所以我们拍了他说的所有这些话，比如像这个，像那个，像这样，像那样。
It was so hard not to laugh. I did laugh at like a ham because it wasn't on the piece of paper so I was not expecting it. You didn't see it coming. No. No. So that my response is definitely like take four or five because I remember everyone just lost it when he said it and then they were like, okay, wait, that's good.
忍住不笑太难了。我确实因为“像火腿一样”这句笑了，因为它不在纸上，所以我完全没有料到。你没有预料到。没有。没有。所以我的反应绝对是第四或第五条，因为我记得当他说出那句话时所有人都笑喷了，然后他们说：“好吧，等等，这个好。”
That's good. That's the one we want. And they were like, pull it together and do it again. Do it again. Okay. I have a question for you. When he says shut up, I know exactly what to do. Was that improvised?
这个好。这就是我们要的。然后他们说：“收起情绪，再来一条。”再来一条。好的。我有个问题问你。当他说“闭嘴，我知道该怎么做”时。那是即兴发挥吗？
That I don't remember. I don't remember because I do think that that final look to camera was that was some direction I was given, which is like, I know the cameras out there. Yeah. And your look to camera is like, can this day get any worse? It's like so weird. I'm not getting any gifts. No.
那个我不记得了。我不记得了，因为我觉得最后看向镜头的那个镜头是导演给我的指导，大概意思是，我知道镜头就在那里。对。你看着镜头的眼神就像是：“这一天还能再糟糕点吗？”太奇怪了。我没有收到任何礼物。不。
Jim has barely acknowledged me and Dwight just asked for my help and then told me to shut up. I also love when rain, how rain responds to me saying like, she's a little like tightly wound. Oh gosh. Yeah. He like chose to be like turned on by it. It's so gross.
吉姆几乎没理我，而德怀特刚刚向我寻求帮助，然后叫我闭嘴。我也很喜欢雷恩，雷恩对我说“她有点像发条上得太紧”的反应。哦，天哪。对。他居然选择被这个吸引。太恶心了。
Kind of creepy. Did you notice how many times we were in scenes in the break room in the kitchen? Like in this episode, we're in quite a few, I think we have like three break room scenes, two kitchen scenes. So it's interesting and I don't know if that's because they were constantly trying to keep Jim and Pam apart or there were these secret conversations about relationships. But I feel like this was a very interesting episode for that reason because a lot of the scenes don't actually happen in the bullpen.
有点让人毛骨悚然。你们有没有注意到我们在茶水间和厨房的场景有多少次？就像在这集中，我们有相当多的场景，我觉得我们有大约三个茶水间场景，两个厨房场景。所以这很有趣，我不知道这是否是因为他们一直在试图让吉姆和帕姆保持距离，或者有这些关于关系的秘密对话。但我觉得这也是这一集非常有趣的原因，因为很多场景实际上并不是在大办公室里发生的。
Yeah. They're not at our desks this time. Yeah. So Jim is in the break room with Kelly and he's kind of trying to give her advice. He's really just trying to eat his bag of chips. He tells her to take it slow and then Ryan walks in. She asked him out in front of Jim and John's the way John played this moment like he's like not in front of me.
对。这次他们不在办公桌前。对。所以吉姆在茶水间跟凯利在一起，他有点试图给她一些建议。他其实只是想吃他的薯片。他告诉她慢慢来，然后瑞恩走了进来。她在吉姆面前约他，而约翰演这个时刻的方式就好像“别当着我的面”。
Oh. He's like, oh no, not while I'm here. No, please. Oh, so good. But Ryan shoots her down. He says, I can't. I have plans with friends and I can't. It's so cringy.
哦。他就像是，“哦不，别在我在这的时候。”不，求你了。哦，太棒了。但瑞恩拒绝了她。他说：“我不能。我有朋友的安排，我不能。”太尴尬了。
And she's like, oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And Jim is just sitting there.
而她就像是，“哦，好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧。”而吉姆就坐在那儿。
Just sitting there. Like get me out of here. There are gifts for Phyllis and Meredith is drinking heavily. She's had it. Yeah. She's full on mixing up a cocktail. She sure is. And that super gulp.
就坐在那儿。就像“快把我弄出去吧”。那里有送给菲莉丝的礼物，而梅雷迪思在狂饮。她受够了。对。她直接在调鸡尾酒了。她确实在调。还有那个超大杯饮料。
I have been to family reunions where I have one or two aunts that walk around with a giant 7-Eleven super gulp and I'm always like. What's in there? What's in there? Why are you nursing on that 7-Eleven super gulp all day? Well, I used to do an opposite thing in college. So I was not a big drinker, but I wanted to go to the parties and not be judged. So you'd bring a super gulp full of like soda?
我参加过家庭聚会，我有那一两个阿姨，她们手里拿着7-11的超大杯饮料到处走，我总是想。里面装的是什么？里面装的是什么？你为什么一整天都在啜饮那个7-11的超大杯？嗯，我上大学时做过相反的事。所以我不是个爱喝酒的人，但我想去派对又不想被人评判。所以你会带一杯装满苏打水的超大杯？
I would bring a red solo cup full. Your own solo cup to the party? I had my own red solo cup and then I would put something non-alcoholic in it. And you'd be like, I'm good. I've got my drink. Yeah, I got it. I'm good. I'm fine.
我会带一个装满的红色独奏杯。你带了自己的独奏杯去派对？我有自己的红色独奏杯，然后我会在里面装点无酒精的东西。然后你就可以说：“我很好。我有我的饮料。”对，我有。我很好。我很好。
I'm good. I don't need to get drunk on whatever you're handing out weird frat boy party. Oh my gosh. Have solo cup. We'll travel. Yeah. Exactly. So I did like an opposite thing, a reverse Meredith.
我很好。我不需要在你们分发的那些奇怪的兄弟会派对上喝醉。天哪。带上独奏杯，随时出发。对。完全正确。所以我做了相反的事，一个反向的梅雷迪思。
Should we go back to New York and meet our CFO, David Wallace? Yeah, because it's about to really go south. And also, I mean, oh God, how funny is Faces of Scranton? I don't want to jump ahead, but that is some funny shiitake. Yeah. It's time for the presentations. Josh Porter gives a nice, normal presentation. Yes.
我们是不是该回纽约去见我们的首席财务官大卫·华莱士了？对，因为事情要急转直下了。而且，我的天哪，斯克兰顿的面孔太搞笑了？我不想剧透，但那真的是些好笑的东西。对。是时候进行演示了。乔什·波特做了一个不错且正常的演示。是的。
And you know, in the DVD commentary, Mike Scherr said, it was really important to him that you saw a range of competence in the branch managers. A range of competence. Yes. I like that phrase. I'm paraphrasing. I don't know that he said that exactly. But like Josh Porter is on it.
而且你知道，在DVD评论音轨里，迈克·舒尔说，看到分公司经理们能力各不相同对他来说非常重要。能力各不相同。是的。我喜欢这个短语。我在意译。我不知道他是不是原话这么说的。但就像乔什·波特完全掌控全局。
He's got his presentation. He's got it down. And then you have, you know, Michael's kind of somewhere in the middle. Yeah. Because he does actually have a binder. He hands something out. Yeah. And then you have Craig, who didn't prepare at all.
他有他的演示文稿。他准备得很充分。然后你有，你知道的，迈克尔大概处于中间水平。对。因为他确实有一个文件夹。他分发了一些东西。对。然后你有克雷格，他根本没做准备。
Right. And Dan, we don't get to see. Well, actually, he's sort of finishing his and he goes, and that's how we're doing it or whatever. Yeah. I think Mike was saying it was important that they wanted to show that, that although Michael Scott does this crazy video, that he also did come prepared. He's not, he's not like Craig.
对的。而丹，我们没能看到。好吧，其实他有点在收尾，他说，“事情就是这样的”或者诸如此类的话。对。我想迈克是想表达，向大家展示这一点很重要，尽管迈克尔·斯科特做了这个疯狂的视频，但他也确实是有备而来的。他不是，他不像克雷格。
He's not completely incompetent. Yes. Well, let's talk about that video. When Michael starts his presentation, he presents faces of Scranton, which is a video of the people at the Scranton branch set to. With or without you. Yeah. By you too.
他不是完全无能。是的。好吧，我们来聊聊那个视频。当迈克尔开始他的演示时，他展示了《斯克兰顿的面孔》，这是一个以斯克兰顿分公司员工为主角的视频，配乐是。With or without you。对。U2乐队的。
Yeah. How could we afford that? And it's- We must have blown our whole budget on that song. And it's like not in slow motion, but it's not in regular motion. It's- It's a little slow down. It's a little slow down.
对。我们怎么负担得起这个？这绝对是-我们一定把整个预算都花在这首歌上了。而且它不是慢动作，但它也不是正常速度。它-它稍微放慢了一点。它稍微放慢了一点。
So everyone is like blinking real slow and waving the camera real slow. Yeah. Walking slowly, sitting slowly. We had a fan question from Rebecca Heaven. She said, did Steve actually film the footage from the business meeting presentation video? Did you get any intel when you were talking with Randall about how they made faces of Scranton? Randall said that he filmed that specifically for this episode.
所以每个人看起来都在非常缓慢地眨眼，非常缓慢地对着镜头挥手。对。缓慢地走路，缓慢地坐着。我们收到了来自丽贝卡·海文的粉丝提问。她说，史蒂夫真的拍摄了商务会议演示视频里的那些镜头吗？当你和兰德尔交谈时，有没有得到关于他们是如何制作《斯克兰顿的面孔》的内幕？兰德尔说那是他专门为这一集拍摄的。
Okay. It wasn't pieced together from other footage. That was my question. Yeah. That he actually filmed that. I notice I'm wearing the wardrobe from Boys and Girls. Did you notice? I did not.
好的。它不是从其他素材里拼凑出来的。那是我的问题。对。他是真的拍了那些镜头。我注意到我穿着《男女有别》里的戏服。你注意到了吗？我没有。
Yeah. I filmed it the week prior because I'm in my Boys and Girls wardrobe, which we filmed the episode before this one. And you're not spray tanned. I'm not tan. In Faces of Scranton. I'm not tan and I'm in my pink sweater with my low ponytail. Oh, okay.
对。我是在前一周拍的，因为我穿着《男女有别》里的戏服，我们是在这一集之前的那集拍的。而且你没有喷雾美黑。我不黑。在《斯克兰顿的面孔》里。我不黑，我穿着粉色毛衣扎着低马尾。哦，好吧。
Yeah. So that, I think we filmed it right before, but- I'm happy to hear that because my memory was that those shots were scripted in the script, but there was a description of Faces of Scranton, particularly I remember getting those shots of him like over my shoulder with the, like the dialogue was scripted and then there were suggestions of what the shots should be. Definitely. The whole scene where I have the brownies and I'm looking kind of sour at him.
对。所以，我想我们是刚拍完那个，但是-我很高兴听到这个，因为我的记忆是，那些镜头在剧本里是有剧本安排的，但对《斯克兰顿的面孔》有一个描述，特别是，我记得拍到他从我肩膀后方拍的那些镜头，比如台词是剧本写好的，然后有一些关于镜头应该是什么样的建议。当然。我拿着布朗尼蛋糕并且对他表现得有点脸色难看的整个场景。
That was all like planned out. Phil Shea had the brownies. The whole thing. Yeah. So Randall shot that specifically for this and there were beats that he had to hit. Now the great thing is, you guys, if you love it, go to the DVD extras because there's extended footage. What you see is actually condensed.
那都是计划好的。菲尔·谢伊准备了布朗尼蛋糕。整套流程都是。对。所以兰德尔是专门为了这个拍摄的，而且他必须卡准节拍。现在最棒的是，伙计们，如果你喜欢它，去看看DVD花絮，因为有加长片段。你们看到的其实是精简版。
There's actually more footage of Faces of Scranton. Maybe that's the version that Michael submits to the film festivals. Well, but he tells, so he's like, but you know what, maybe, maybe it's not appropriate. Maybe not. Maybe he will. Maybe he won't. Maybe he won't. He's not sure.
实际上还有更多《斯克兰顿的面孔》的镜头。也许那是迈克尔提交给电影节的版本。好吧，但他跟人说，所以他觉得，“但你知道吗，也许，也许这不太合适。也许不合适。也许他会。也许他不会。也许他不会。”他不确定。
The video doesn't go over well. Melora's reaction as Jan is just amazing. Melora, you crushed it. I loved it. So David just asked for his sales numbers. He's like, can I just get your sales numbers? And I was really worried for a second. I was like, oh no, but no, Michael has those two.
这个视频反响不佳。梅洛拉作为简的反应简直绝了。梅洛拉，你演得太棒了。我太喜欢了。所以大卫刚刚要他的销售数据。他说：“我能看一下你们的销售数据吗？”我有一秒钟真的很担心。我想：“哦不，不过还好，迈克尔有那两份。”
He hands out some little binders. He was prepared. He had binders all ready to go. That's Michael in a nutshell. He's trying to be outside the box. He's trying to tug on your heartstrings and make. This is his whole thing. He wants the work to be more than just a binder of numbers.
他分发了一些小文件夹。他是做好了准备的。他把文件夹都准备好了。这就是迈克尔的典型作风。他试图打破常规。他试图触动你的心弦，并制造。这就是他的全部作风。他希望工作不仅仅是一堆数字文件夹。
He wants it to be about people. That the thing is, they are his family. Yes. You know, things move at a slower pace. The song is with or without you. It does. It has nothing to do in the workplace. No.
他希望它是关于人的。事实是，他们就是他的家人。是的。你知道的，事情的节奏较慢。这首歌是《With or without you》。确实如此。这和工作场所完全无关。不。
Like what is, it's like a, like a love song. Yeah. And, and just when he was like, I spend a day in Phyllis's pants. What does he say? Spend a day in Phyllis's pants is not what he says. Spend. Well, he says, like, see what it's like to walk a day in Oscar's shoes or sit in Phyllis's pants.
就像什么，这就像是一首情歌。对。就在他说，“体验一下菲莉丝的裤子”的时候。他说的是什么？体验一下菲莉丝的裤子可不是他说的话。体验。好吧，他说，就像，“看看体验一把奥斯卡的鞋子或者坐在菲莉丝的裤子里是什么感觉。”
I don't know what he says about Phyllis's pants. It's right as she's sitting down. Right as she's sitting down. Right as she's sitting down. I just love it. I hope this gave you a little taste of what life is like here at Dunder Mifflin Scranton. What it's like to walk a mile in Oscar's shoes or try on Phyllis's pants. There it is.
我不知道他关于菲莉丝的裤子是怎么说的。就在她坐下的时候。就在她坐下的时候。就在她坐下的时候。我太喜欢了。我希望这能让你们对邓德米夫林斯克兰顿的生活有个初步的了解。体验一下奥斯卡鞋子的感觉或者试穿一下菲莉丝的裤子。就是这样。
Or try on Phyllis's pants. Okay. Okay. So he says, try on Phyllis's pants in slow mo as she's sitting down. Yes. Faces of Scranton. And then the very end. Great Scott.
或者试穿菲莉丝的裤子。好吧。好吧。所以他说，在慢动作中试穿菲莉丝的裤子，当时她正坐下来。是的。《斯克兰顿的面孔》。然后是最后。太棒了，斯科特。
Mike said was, Mike sure said that was an afterthought that he just sort of added that last minute and they made it, but it's so funny. It's so funny. So funny. All right. So now we're going to go back to the office again after that presentation and Oscar is going to get some flowers. Not flowers.
迈克说，迈克·舒尔说那是个事后才想到的点子，他只是在最后一分钟加进去的，他们把它做出来了，但太搞笑了。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。好的。所以现在在看完那个演示后我们要回办公室了，奥斯卡将收到一些鲜花。不是花。
He got a plant. Well, yeah. Which I think is perfect. Perfect. And he reads the card. He says they're from his mom. And I loved his choice of putting the card in his pocket. Yeah.
他收到了一盆植物。嗯，对。我觉得这很完美。完美。他读了卡片。他说那是他妈妈送的。我很喜欢他把卡片放进口袋里的选择。对。
He puts it in his pocket. Puts it in his pocket. Meredith has passed out. There's nothing for Pam. There's nothing for Angela. Yeah. And Meredith is going to sleep this one out. Here's a fan catch at 14 minutes, 45 seconds.
他把它放进口袋里。放进口袋里。梅雷迪思已经晕过去了。没有帕姆的份。没有安吉拉的份。对。而梅雷迪思打算直接睡过去。这里有个粉丝在14分45秒发现的彩蛋。
Adam West 84 says there's a huge week calendar on the wall beside accounting that you can see from both accounting and from reception. It's always there. It's always there. It's a dry erase board calendar. Yes. He said it has always bothered him that they abbreviate Thursday as THUS. Instead of THUR, and he said, quote, it breaks my mind.
亚当·韦斯特84说，在会计部旁边墙上有一个巨大的每周日历，你从会计部和前台都能看到。它一直都在那儿。它一直都在那儿。那是一个干擦白板日历。是的。他说一直让他感到困扰的是他们把星期四缩写为THUS。而不是THUR，他说，“这简直快把我逼疯了。”
Well, I need to go back and see that 14 minutes, 45 seconds. I mean, I know. I do remember the handwriting was a bit sloppy. There is a chance that R looks like an S if it's in cursive. I'm going to go and look at it. I'm going to go check it. So you're thinking it's THUR. You know what?
好吧，我得回去看看那14分45秒。我的意思是，我懂。我确实记得字迹有点潦草。如果用连笔写的话，R看起来确实有点像S。我要去看看。我要去检查一下。所以你觉得它是THUR。你知道吗？
I'll tell you what. It's not written in cursive. The days of the week are taped out in block letters, THUS thus. That would make me crazy too. Yeah, it's really bothering Adam. That's a crazy good catch. I'm going to go check it out. And I think it's just always that way.
我告诉你吧。它不是用连笔写的。星期几是用印刷体胶带贴上去的，写的是THUS。那也会把我逼疯的。对，亚当真的很困扰。这是一个超级棒的发现。我要去核实一下。而且我觉得它一直都是那样的。
I can't wait. I can't wait to go check it out. All right. So next, Jim's in the kitchen with Kelly. And he's giving her, like, he is being a good friend, actually. He's being gentle. And he's like, you know what, he's just not into you. It would be great if he was, but he's not.
我等不及了。我等不及要去核实了。好的。接下来，吉姆在茶水间和凯利在一起。他在给她，他其实表现得像个好朋友。他很温柔。他说：“你知道吗，他对你没感觉。如果他有感觉那就太好了，但他没有。”
So you just have to suck it up. Both Jim and Pam are saying to others. They're giving advice to others in this episode. Pam gives advice to Dwight. And she says something where it's just Pam projecting, where she says, you know, it's just you want her to think that you thought of her. Yeah. It's not what you give her.
“所以你只能接受现实。”吉姆和帕姆都在对别人说。他们在这一集中给别人提供建议。帕姆给德怀特提出了建议。她说了一些话，其实就是帕姆在投射自我，她说：“你知道，你只是想让她觉得你想到了她。”对。这不在于你送她什么。
It's that she knows you thought of her. Right. And that's desperately what Pam wants. She just wants to feel like Roy thinks of her. That he ever, ever thinks of her. And then Jim is saying to Kelly, look, it'd be nice if he was into you, but he's not. You just got to let it go. And of course, Jim is talking about Pam.
而在于她知道你想到了她。对。而这正是帕姆极度渴望的。她只是想觉得罗伊想到了她。觉得他曾经、哪怕有一刻想到了她。然后吉姆对凯利说：“听着，他对你有感觉固然好，但他就是没有。你只能放手。”当然，吉姆说的是帕姆。
Yes. Yes. And Kelly doesn't hear any of it. Kelly does not get it. She's like, you know, he invites her to poker and she's like, can I invite Ryan? Yeah. And the face, the face John does when he, she says that is like, come on, come on. Kelly.
对。对。凯莉什么都没听进去。凯莉根本不懂。她就觉得，你知道的，他邀请她去打扑克，她就问：我可以带瑞安一起去吗？对。约翰当时的那个表情，当她这么说的时候，那表情就像是：拜托，拜托，凯莉。
All right. So again, back to New York, we go back and forth between New York and Scranton a lot in this episode. Yes. This is when we find out that Craigers did not prepare anything for the meeting because he thought it was more of a meet and greet. Well, he's also just a slacker. He's a slacker.
好。所以话说回来，我们又回到了纽约，这一集里我们一直在纽约和斯克兰顿之间来回切换。没错。这就是我们发现克雷格斯为会议什么都没准备的时候，因为他以为这更像是一个见面会。好吧，他其实也就是个偷懒的人。他就是个偷懒鬼。
He's a slacker. And he ignores direct orders. I think his performance is so delicious. And he kind of gets in trouble. Jan says, this does not bode well for your branch. And then he throws her under the bus. Yeah. I mean, I guess I'd get better treatment, you know, if we hooked up, like that's what
他就是个偷懒鬼。而且他还无视直接命令。我觉得他的表现太绝了。而且他差不多惹上麻烦了。简说：这对你的分公司可不是什么好兆头。然后他就把简给卖了。对。我的意思是，我想如果我和你发生了关系，我大概会受到更好的待遇，你知道的，他暗示的就是这个，对吧？
he's inferring, right? Cause you hooked up with Michael, he flat out says Michael made a stupid movie and didn't get in any trouble. Maybe I should have slept with you too. Oh yeah. Boom. Screech. This heads us into the Jan Michael scene and Jan is just so defeated.
因为你和迈克尔好过，他直截了当说迈克尔拍了一部烂电影却什么麻烦也没惹。也许我也该跟你睡一觉。哦，天哪。哇塞。刺耳。这就把我们带入了简和迈克尔的场景，简简直沮丧透了。
She's like, Michael, it's like, I can't, yeah, I can't believe it. Like, you don't understand for the new CFO to find out that I would have slept with an employee is she's like, I can't believe you. Why? Why are you you? And Michael just says he's going to fix it. He's going to talk to David Wallace and you just see Michael loves Jan so much. He feels so bad.
她就像是：迈克尔，这简直，我简直，天哪，我真不敢相信。就像是，你根本不明白，让新首席财务官发现我和一个员工睡过，她就像是：我真不敢相信你。为什么？你为什么总是你？而迈克尔只说他会解决这件事。他会去跟大卫·华莱士谈谈，你能看出迈克尔是多么深爱简。他觉得太糟糕了。
Like I think he finally gets it. He's like, wow. He, he feels bad. He feels bad, but he still makes a really lame joke. So he's like, and don't call me Shirley. Yeah. He can't resist. I'm just being an idiot.
就像我觉得他终于明白了。他心里想：哇。他感到很糟糕，他感到很糟糕，但他还是开了一个非常烂的玩笑。所以他说：还有，别叫我雪莉。对。他忍不住。我就是个白痴。
He can't resist it. Yeah. He's trying to make her feel better and then has to like put a joke in and look to camera. Oh, Michael. So I'm going to jump ahead to the scene where Michael does go into David Wallace's office and then we'll go back to Dunder Mifflin and talk about what's happening there. But Michael does go into David Wallace's office and he says, it's not true. I didn't sleep with Jan.
他根本忍不住。对。他正试图让她感觉好点，然后又不得不开个玩笑，还看着镜头。哦，迈克尔。所以我要跳到迈克尔去找大卫·华莱士谈话的那个场景，然后我们再回到邓德米夫林，聊聊那里发生了什么。不过迈克尔确实去了大卫·华莱士的办公室，他说：这不是真的。我没有和简睡觉。
I just made a joke. This is all my fault. Yeah. It's a joke. It was a bad joke. I'm so sorry. And Jan kind of perks up like, oh yes, it's a joke. It's totally a joke.
我只是开个玩笑。这全都是我的错。对。是个玩笑。那是个很烂的玩笑。非常抱歉。简有点振作起来，心想：哦，是的，是个玩笑。完全是个玩笑。
It didn't happen. And David Wallace kind of accepts this. He's like, okay. Michael promises it will never happen again. And all is forgiven. Like they don't get in trouble. It's okay. I want you to know that I noticed something on David Wallace's desk in this scene.
根本没发生过。大卫·华莱士算是接受了这种说法。他就像是：好吧。迈克尔保证这种事绝不会再发生。一切都被原谅了。就像他们不会惹上麻烦一样。没事的。我想让你们知道，在这个场景里我注意到大卫·华莱士的桌上有个东西。
What? At 19 minutes, 24 seconds, David Wallace has a world's best boss mug. Oh my God. But it's black with white cursive writing. Nice catch, lady. Yeah. Yeah. If you freeze frame it.
什么？在19分24秒的时候，大卫·华莱士有一个“世界最佳老板”马克杯。天哪。但它是黑色的，上面有白色的花体字。眼光不错嘛，女士。对。对。如果你定格画面。
Oh, that's a really good catch. That's a really good catch. Yeah. Oh, wow. I have to imagine that that was a choice and that they, that's a very subtle Phil Shea thing. Yes. Yeah.
哦，这真是个绝佳的细节。这真是个绝佳的细节。对。哦，天哪。我敢说这绝对是刻意安排的，而且那是菲尔·谢伊非常微妙的小心思。对。对。
That's the kind of sense of humor that Phil Shea has, that he gave him a world's best boss mug on his desk. I love that. Isn't that great? All right. So back at the office, Angela finally gets her gift from Dwight. Yes. It is a key.
这就是菲尔·谢伊的那种幽默感，他在大卫的桌上放了一个“世界最佳老板”马克杯。我太喜欢这个了。是不是很棒？好。所以回到办公室，安吉拉终于收到了来自德怀特的礼物。对。那是一把钥匙。
Angela, your performance in this scene is so good. Oh. I feel is that you, you get this key and you're like, what is this just a key? Like I feel like I could hear your whole interior monologue. What is this? This is a key. I don't even know what this, oh, oh, oh, like you're so delighted. It's so great.
安吉拉，你在这个场景里的表现太棒了。哦。我觉得就是，你拿到了这把钥匙，然后你的反应是：什么？这只是一把钥匙吗？就像我觉得我能听到你内心所有的独白。这是什么？这是一把钥匙。我甚至不知道这，哦，哦，哦，就像你太高兴了。太棒了。
I had a fan question, Jenny this Lynn asks, was the key Dwight gave Angela for her to move in or just for her to have when she wants to stay there? What do you think? I think it's an all access pass. I don't think I move in. We're not ready for that. Yeah. But it means I get to come and go now as I please.
我有一个粉丝提问，珍妮，这个叫琳的人问：德怀特给安吉拉的钥匙是让她搬进来住的，还是只是为了方便她想留在那儿的时候用？你觉得呢？我觉得这是个全通道通行证。我不认为我搬进去了。我们还没准备好走到那一步。对。但这意味着我现在可以随心所欲地自由出入了。
Yes. That's, I had the same interpretation. Yes. That's what I think too. And she's thrilled by it. And in the bloopers, one of my favorite bloopers from this episode, they're on YouTube. There was the thought at first that Dwight would give her this gift with a card. Okay.
对。这就是，我的理解是一样的。对。我也是这么想的。而且她为此欣喜若狂。在片尾花絮里，这一集里我最喜欢的花絮之一，它们在YouTube上。大家一开始以为德怀特会送她这个礼物并附上一张卡片。好吧。
Okay. Uh-huh. And he wanted Jim's help in writing a card for a girl, for a girl. He doesn't say who it's for. And so he starts, Jim doesn't want to help him really. He gives him a hard time and Dwight's like annoyed. So Dwight is sitting here trying to write this card and Jim is hearing all of it. And they're in the bloopers and it is hilarious.
好吧。呃-huh。他想让吉姆帮他给一个女孩写张卡片，为一个女孩。他没说那是给谁的。所以他开始写，吉姆其实并不想帮他。吉姆为难他，德怀特觉得很烦。所以德怀特就坐在那儿试图写这张卡片，吉姆把这一切都听在眼里。他们当时在拍花絮，简直太爆笑了。
But if you want to see John Krasinski break really hard, watch the bloopers on YouTube. And Dwight writes, you are evil like a hobbit. This was the Valentine's card he might give Angela and John loses it. So that's a fun blooper moment. Well next up, Roy comes in and Pam is done. Yeah. She's very annoyed. Yeah.
但如果你想看约翰·卡拉辛斯基笑场笑得有多惨，去YouTube看花絮吧。然后德怀特写道：你像霍比特人一样邪恶。这就是他可能送给安吉拉的情人节卡片，约翰直接笑崩了。所以那是一个很有趣的花絮时刻。接下来，罗伊进来了，帕姆已经受够了。对。她非常恼火。对。
And Roy is like, what's wrong? Are you upset? And she's like, yeah, I mean, I know I said don't spend a lot, but I thought I'd get something. But not only that, the person that fills in the blanks when Roy consistently fails is Jim. Yeah. And he didn't fill in the blanks.
罗伊就问：怎么了？你不高兴吗？她就说：对，我的意思是，我知道我说过不要花太多钱，但我以为我至少能收到点什么。不仅如此，当罗伊一如既往地掉链子时，那个把空缺填补上的人总是吉姆。对。而且他这次没填补空缺。
Nope. She's filling it more than ever. It's magnified. She didn't get a cute little card from Jim this year. He gave her nothing this year. Nothing. Yeah. But Roy tells her, it's not over yet, baby.
没有。她比以往任何时候都更能感受到这种空白。这种感觉被放大了。今年她没有收到来自吉姆的可爱小卡片。他今年什么都没给她。什么都没有。对。但罗伊告诉她：还没结束呢，宝贝。
Yeah. Let's get you home and you're going to have the best sex of your life. The reaction to that was so perfect. Oh my gosh. We had a fan question from Joanie Woods. What is the worst Valentine's gift you've ever received? Have you ever gotten anything worse than what Pam gets from Roy? The best sex of her life.
对。我们这就回家，你会享受到你人生中最棒的性爱。听到这话时的反应简直太完美了。哦，天哪。我们收到了来自乔尼·伍兹的一个粉丝提问：你收过的最糟糕的情人节礼物是什么？你有没有收到过比帕姆从罗伊那里得到的还要糟糕的礼物？她人生中最棒的性爱。
Oh my gosh. I mean, I was dating a guy one time and he got me salsa. Really? Was it special? Was it from somewhere that you enjoyed salsa together? No. Someone, this wasn't a bad gift. Okay.
哦，天哪。我的意思是，我曾经和一个男生交往过，他送了我一罐萨尔萨辣酱。真的吗？是很特别的吗？是你们曾经一起去过的某个你很喜欢的萨尔萨辣酱店买的吗？不是。有人，这倒不是说是个糟糕的礼物。好吧。
It was just odd. It was just odd. It was homemade salsa? Did he make it? No. A co-worker made it. I think the co-worker gave it to him. Okay.
就只是很奇怪。就只是很奇怪。是自制的萨尔萨酱吗？他自己做的吗？不是。是一个同事做的。我觉得是那个同事送给他的。好吧。
And then he was like, oh, I got you salsa, maybe. Do you like salsa? I like it okay. It's I mean, it's like kind of getting like a condiment. Like here's some mayonnaise, happy Valentine's. My friend makes their own mayonnaise and listen, I tried it. It was good salsa. But it was kind of like, okay, well, I think I see the writing on the wall here.
然后他就说：哦，我给你弄了点萨尔萨酱，也许吧。你喜欢萨尔萨酱吗？我还行吧。我的意思是，这就有点像是送你一种调味品。就像是：给你点蛋黄酱，情人节快乐。我的朋友自己做蛋黄酱，你们听我说，我尝过。那萨尔萨酱其实挺不错的。但感觉就好像是：好吧，我想我看到这其中的苗头不对了。
How much longer did you guys date? Not much longer. Really? Yeah. Not much. Just a few more months later. Shocker. But you know, I am not like, I don't need a big gift.
你们俩又交往了多久？没多久。真的吗？对。没多久。也就几个月之后就分了。毫不意外。但你知道，我并不是那种人，我不需要什么大礼。
It's kind of like that thing. If you thought of me great. Yeah. But it was just really random. And I really, really think his co-worker made everyone salsa for Valentine's and he basically gave me. He re-gifted. He re-gifted salsa.
就那种感觉：只要你心里想着我，就很棒了。对。但这真的太随机了。而且我真的、真的很觉得他同事是给每个人都做了情人节萨尔萨酱，而他基本上就是把我转送了。他转送了萨尔萨辣酱。
What about you? I can't think of a worst gift. I can't think of a best gift either. I think most of my Valentine's days have come and gone without much fanfare. I mean, I love flowers. I do. Flowers are nice. Even fashion that way.
你呢？我想不出最糟糕的礼物是什么。我也想不出最好的礼物是什么。我觉得我的大部分情人节都是平平淡淡、毫无 fanfare 地度过的。我的意思是，我喜欢花。我是真的喜欢。花挺好看的。甚至在这方面很传统。
I love flowers. And you know what? My husband was like, Ange, I am not a mind reader. I am not good at this. If you want something for Valentine's, you have to tell me because I am going to get it wrong. So I just said to him, when we first got married, I was like, babe, just always get me flowers and I'll be happy.
我喜欢花。你知道吗？我丈夫当时就说：安吉，我可不会读心术。我不擅长这个。如果你想要什么情人节礼物，你得告诉我，因为我自己挑肯定会买错。所以我刚结婚时就对他说：亲爱的，只要一直给我买花，我就会很高兴。
You can put two of my wife from, two wife, one year it was two Simicola and wife from Simicola and husband. But it was roses. I'm happy. You got me flowers. I just like to get a nice card with a little note on it. I think that's why, you know, I married a writer, write me something good and a card and I'm happy.
你可以把我的名字写两次，写“致妻子”，有一年是两瓶西米科拉红酒，写着“致妻子，来自西米科拉和丈夫”。但那是玫瑰花。我很开心。你给我买花了。我只是喜欢收到一张写着几行暖心话语的漂亮卡片。我想这就是为什么，你知道的，我嫁给了一个作家，在卡片上给我写点美好的东西，我就很开心了。
And that's what he does. Generally. Two wife. Two wife. From husband. I guess very different. That's why you need the flowers. I want the flowers, guys.
他通常就是这么做的。致妻子。致妻子。来自丈夫。我猜非常不一样。这就是为什么你需要花。我想要花，伙计们。
All right. So now, you know, Pam just so desperately wants Jim to acknowledge her in any way today. And he doesn't. No. He kind of taps her desk says happy Valentine's Day and your little bye is the saddest thing at the end. So sad. I'm like, bye.
好啦，现在，你知道的，帕姆非常迫切地希望吉姆今天能以任何方式对她有所表示。而他没有。没有。他只是敲了敲她的桌子，说了一声情人节快乐，而你那声小小的“拜拜”是结尾最让人难过的事。太难过了。我当时就想：拜拜。
When I go home, get the best sex of my life. I can't wait. Happy Valentine's Day to me. Per Roy. Yeah. What is, what level of investment is that from Roy? I don't even want to think about it. And then Phyllis and the enormous bear, you know, the writers just wanted to see her carry
等我回家，去享受我人生中最棒的性爱。我等不及了。祝我情人节快乐。罗伊牌的。对。从罗伊身上能看到什么水平的投入度？我甚至都不愿去想。然后是菲利斯和那只巨大的熊，你知道的，编剧们就是想看她抱着
that bear. Oh my gosh. We got a lot of questions about where did that bear come from? And I'm sorry I couldn't get you an answer, but where did that bear come from? I don't know. That's insane. That's a Phyllis Shea classic. Now in the deleted scenes, there is a, there's one that is hilarious.
那只熊。哦，天哪。我们收到了很多关于那只熊是从哪儿来的提问？我很抱歉没能给你们一个答案，但这只熊到底是打哪儿来的？我不知道。太疯狂了。那是菲尔·谢伊的经典之作。现在在删减片段里，有一个片段简直太爆笑了。
Michael actually gives all the ladies a Valentine. Yes. So in Pam's talking head at the beginning, she talks about how people at the office hand things out. And there's actually a bunch of deleted scenes of people handing things out, including Michael, who hands out a bunch of plastic roses. Plastic roses that have thorns. And then his card says, me so thorny.
迈克尔实际上给所有的女士们都送了情人节礼物。是的。所以一开始帕姆的独白里，她谈到办公室里的人们会分发小物件。实际上还有一堆关于大家分发礼物的删减片段，其中包括迈克尔，他分发了一堆塑料玫瑰。带刺的塑料玫瑰。然后他的卡片上写着：我好扎手。
Yeah. Oh. That's what we all wanted. And then one other deleted scene before we wrap up this episode, you guys, is that when Michael is walking on the streets of New York, he walks past Devon. Oh, yes. And Devon recognizes him and is ticked off and kind of chases after him. Yes.
是的。哦。这正是我们大家一直想要的。然后在这个剧集结束前还有另一个删减片段，伙计们，那就是当迈克尔走在纽约街头时，他从德文身旁走过。哦，是的。德文认出了他，气不打一处来，还追了上去。是的。
Because Devon was now in real life living in New York and doing theater. So they called him up when they were going to be in New York to have this additional cameo. And unfortunately, it did not make the cut. It's a very funny deleted scene though. So you guys have to go check it out. And Michael has a talking head about it. It's also deleted.
因为德文当时现实生活中住在纽约并从事戏剧表演。所以当他们得知要在纽约拍摄时就打电话给他来客串这个额外的镜头。但不幸的是，这个镜头没有被剪进正片。不过这是一个非常搞笑的删减片段。所以你们一定要去看看。而且迈克尔还有一个关于这件事的独白。那也是删减片段。
Well, the very end of this episode, Jan catches Michael as he's getting in the elevator at corporate. And she just says, thank you, Michael. Thank you so much. And he's like, yeah, okay. Once again, he's oddly impressed her. Yes. And he's very calm and he's clearly like, I get it.
好吧，这一集的最后，简在总公司的电梯口拦住了迈克尔。她只是说：谢谢你，迈克尔。非常感谢。而他则回答：好吧，行吧。再一次，他莫名其妙地打动了她。是的。而且他非常冷静，显然一副“我懂了”的样子。
It's over. It's over. And I'm never, ever going to go there again. And then she kisses him. Jan. Jan. You are torturing this man. What are you doing?
一切都结束了。一切都结束了。我再也不会去那种地方了。然后她吻了他。简。简。你简直在折磨这个男人。你在干什么？
Jan, you're self-destructive. Oh, my gosh. And you even see her look around. She looks over her shoulder to see if they're alone. And then she kisses him, but she forgot to look over the other shoulder. But Michael knew immediately. He looked right at camera. And he's like, uh, uh.
简，你太有自我毁灭倾向了。哦，天哪。你甚至能看到她环顾四周。她转过头看身后他们是不是独自在一起。然后她吻了他，但她忘了看另一边肩膀。不过迈克尔立刻就意识到了。他直直地看着镜头。他的表情像是：呃，呃。
And then she looks at camera and she's like, oh, forget about it. Forget about it. Oh boy. And then that is how the episode ends. That is how the episode ends. It's such a good one. And I have, I have kind of a fun journal entry that I wrote. Okay.
然后她看着镜头，露出了：哦，算了吧。算了吧。天哪。然后这一集就这么结束了。这一集就是这样结束的。这一集真的太棒了。而且我，我有一篇写得挺有趣的日记。好吧。
And this week I wrote, John and I have a new goofy walk we do when we pretend to be kid sister and big brother. Well, you have to explain kid sister, big brother, because we've never even talked about that guy. So, John and I, you guys, we would have some downtime between scenes and we would just kind of hang out. And sometimes we'd get a little punchy as the day would go. And, um, John's, when I stand next to John, he's so much taller than me.
这周我写道：约翰和我有一个新的滑稽步态，当我们假装是小妹妹和大哥哥时就会这么走。好吧，你得解释一下什么是“小妹妹和大哥哥”，因为我们从来没谈过那个。所以，约翰和我，伙计们，我们在两场戏之间会有一些休息时间，我们就会到处闲逛。随着时间推移，有时我们会有点情绪高涨，而且，约翰的，当我站在约翰旁边时，他比我高太多了。
We both sort of remembered this childhood doll that you could buy. That was called kid sister that stands about three feet tall and you could hold her hand and kind of make her walk. And John and I made up this whole thing where he would hold my hand and I'd pretend to be the kid sister doll. And he'd go kid sister and I'd go big brother. Yes. And we made up this whole goofy walk and everything.
我们俩不知怎么都想起了小时候可以买的一种玩偶。那种玩偶叫“小妹妹”，身高大约三英尺，你可以拉着她的手让她走动。约翰和我编造了一整套动作，他会拉着我的手，而我则假装自己是那个小妹妹玩偶。他会喊“小妹妹”，我就会喊“大哥哥”。是的。我们编造了整套滑稽的步态和所有东西。
So this is, this is what was happening behind the scenes while we were filming. We loved when you guys did kid sister, big brother. That was very entertaining for our downtime. You guys were a good team. Well. You came up with a new walk. I guess a new goofy walk. We had a new bit to do.
所以，这就是我们在拍摄幕后发生的事情。我们很喜欢你们俩玩“小妹妹”和“大哥哥”。在我们休息的时候，这给我们带来了极大的娱乐。你们俩真是个好搭档。好吧。你们琢磨出了一种新的步态。我猜是一种新的滑稽步态。我们有了新的搞笑桥段可以玩。
All right, you guys, that was the Valentine's episode. Yes. And next up is Dwight's speech, another really good one. Really good. And we'd like to thank Andy Buckley so much for stopping by. Yes. And thank you, Randall Einhorn for all of your insider tidbits. Yes.
好了，伙计们，这就是情人节那一集。是的。接下来是德怀特的演讲，又一集非常精彩的剧集。非常精彩。我们要非常感谢安迪·巴克利百忙之中作客播客。是的。还要感谢兰德尔·艾因霍恩分享的所有独家幕后内幕。是的。
And for more stuff, guys, don't forget to check out the DVD commentary and the bloopers. There's good stuff there. And thank you so much for sending in your questions. Yeah. Happy Valentine's Day, everyone. Happy Valentine's Day. Enjoy your salsa. Angela, wait, can you please, I have a new merchandise idea for Office Ladies.
想了解更多内容，伙计们，别忘了去看看DVD花絮和NG镜头。那里有很多好东西。非常感谢大家发来问题。是的。祝大家情人节快乐。情人节快乐。好好享受你们的萨尔萨辣酱吧。安吉拉，等等，你能不能，我有一个关于“办公室女士”的新周边点子。
It's Valentine's Day salsa. Oh no, that guy's going to crawl out of the woodworks and be like, I think I get a cut of that salsa. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher, our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Gratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com.
那就是情人节萨尔萨辣酱。哦不，那家伙肯定会从哪个犄角旮旯里爬出来说：我觉得我应该从那款辣酱的分红里分一杯羹。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍妮·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮夫尔。我们的主题曲是克里·格拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听本节目的无广告版本以及我们的彩蛋节目“糖果袋”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要获得 Stitcher Premium 的免费一个月试用，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。